[Music]
you're listening to radio
sputnik telling
the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
england are playing the albanians and
nicholas sturgeon the first minister of
scotland
doesn't know who to support you'll get
it
later alba the new alex salmon
party what will it do to the scottish
parliamentary elections on may the 6th
what does it mean
for the future of scotland in the united
kingdom
and as we hurtle towards the end of the
coronavirus lockdown we'll be looking at
what kind of travel plans
you can afford to make and looking at
pretty patel pretty by name
pretty by nature britain's home
secretary
on the immigration issues we'll be
talking about that and much more in the
next three hours this is of course the
mother of all talk shows it is
the open university of the airwaves
there are
no tuition fees and you are positively
encouraged
to speak back to the teacher that would
be me despite
my lack of formal qualifications welcome
to the mother of all talk shows rock and
roll
radio with pictures coming up
radio sputnik we speak your language
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
and this of course is london coming to
you all over the world thanks to the
wonders of the
internet and the aforementioned
sputniknews.com
if you're in washington dc you can
listen in crystal clarity on
fm 105.5
magic numbers there you can listen on am
right across the united states from
burning city to
burning city you can listen all over the
world on sputniknews.com
but if you are one of the half a million
people
every single week now who watches as
well as listens to the show
please listen to this if you are
watching
on facebook please immediately
share share and share again with all of
your friends
all of your contacts on facebook because
big al goridham is always
out to get us and so if you
share you will boost our audience
and we'd be very grateful if you would
you can watch on my own facebook page
and you can watch on rt's multiple
facebook pages
ditto on my own youtube channel
ditto rt's multiple youtube channels
you can watch on twitter where again
last week
a record number of people did you can
watch on
instagram we're back on instagram you
can watch on twitch
you can watch on my telegram channel t
dot me
t t dot me forward slash
george galloway have i missed any of
these platforms they're
multiplying at such a rate
now as i said england were playing the
albanians and it was a real dilemma
for scotland's first minister nicholas
sturgeon
normally she'd be with anyone but
england that's the kind of
knuckle-dragging mentality of scottish
nationalism but supporting the
albanians would have been a stretch why
do i say so
because albanians are coming for her
the new party announced by my erstwhile
parliamentary colleague alex salmond
this week
on friday the alba party
has quite a few followers already
and they are dubbed the albanians
and it's not an in-app
appellation because actually they're
pursuing the
kosovo option what could possibly
go wrong alex almond is at least honest
he told us this day that
if he can get the supermajority
they call it on a minority of the vote
but a
super majority of the seats
by gaming the system are then
immediately the scottish government must
negotiate
independence from the rest of the united
kingdom i'm not making that up
yes they plan a unilateral
declaration of independence again
what could possibly go wrong well
actually
everything they have no plans
for another referendum although
referenda and other democratic tests
may said salmon play some part
in the process but the emphasis
he laid was on great peaceful
demonstrations of popular power in
support
of this unilateral declaration of
independence
it would be of course entirely illegal
it could not be
recognized internationally indeed if
britain sought sanction
against the udi brigade they would
have to be granted by all for our
the european union included the united
nations on which
the united kingdom has a permanent chair
in the security council all
g7 everything all countries would have
to
support the british government in those
circumstances
and of course alex almonds big peaceful
demonstrations would be met on the
streets
by peaceful demonstrations equally
large maybe more large than those
demonstrating
in favor of the illegal act of
independence i can
hardly believe i'm saying these words
because
that would be us off and running in the
direction
of catalonia at best in the direction of
ulster or even yugoslavia
at worst and the british state
would face the prospect of
a failed state on its northern border
a failed state isolated and shunned as
it would have to be
by the world because nobody in the world
can support
illegal acts of secession for fear of
those acts
being repeated in their own country or
in neighboring countries
and an automatic security risk
to the security of the united kingdom
would per se
exist now all of that sounds terribly
apocalyptic
but in just six weeks time that's
exactly where we
might be i don't have time
or space to explain the de hunt
system of election for you but in a
nutshell
it could very well come to pass that the
pro-independence forces
got 45 of the vote
but 70 of the seats
if if those who vote
for the snp the ruling party
in scotland give insufficient numbers
their second vote their regional
proportional
list vote to alex salmon's
alba party now nothing is ever
as good or as bad as it first
appears i learned that lesson a long
long
time ago and so alex salmon's launch
looking like dracula from a very
dark blue broom cupboard
whose video broke down without his
knowledge
after 10 seconds leaving him standing
there looking at the video that nobody
else could see and a series of
defections from the snp announced
with each one being how shall i put it
hairier than the last uh
tommy sheridan uh the last the latest
just as i came on air being their
latest recruit but there are
others about whom a great many question
marks
arise so you could characterize it
so far as the rough trade
end of the snp
but it might get smoother they may have
despite all appearances
to the contrary an actual plan
we may see defections of greater
merit in the hours days
and well not many weeks ahead we may
so we'll be asking tonight the doyan
of political science in britain
professor
sir john curtis of strathclyde
university
what are the different outcomes that may
emerge
from the launching of the albanian
option
it could be that the nationalist parties
eat each other and there are early signs
that that might well happen uh nicola
sturgeon's memory
about alex salmond has suddenly flooded
back
just a week ago in front of the
parliamentary inquiry
she knew nothing gov never heard of any
question mark against her former
mentor her predecessor alex salmond
now that she's under mortal electoral
threat
from him she remembers everything
he's been a problem waiting to happen
all along a man not to be trusted
with the ladies in fact has one wag put
it alba might well be an acronym for all
ladies beware always
something like that now suddenly
sturgeon knows that what if
this goes wrong what if these two wings
of the
nationalist movement sufficiently
tear lumps out of each other that the
middle ground in scotland
gets the garlic out and says no
a plague on both your houses after all
you've been in power for 14 years
and everything in scotland is worse than
it was
before you came to power by any metric
uh the school's performance the health
service performance
the policing performance the judicial
system
performance the manufacturing
performance the jobs performance
the child poverty performance the drugs
death performance
believe me i could go on and on and on
by every
metric scotland is worse today
than it was when the separatists took
over
14 years ago so that's one possible
outcome a second possible outcome
is what salmon says he wants
that the snp win the overwhelmingly the
lion's share
of constituency members of the scottish
parliament
and alex salmond wins a very decent
share of the list votes the
second vote in the proportional
representation
section of the ballot giving what salmon
calls
a super majority which he has said
will be the starting pistol
and i hope i'm using the word pistol
only metaphorically for a series
of udi actions illegal
actions for independence that is also
one possible
outcome a third outcome and we'll be
discussing with professor
curtis is that so discredited will the
election results be
by this transparent gaming of the
political system
two parties uh a facsimile of
each other although the alba one having
rather more
smudges and uh blobs of ink
uh if you get my drift uh that
boris johnson says these elections are
farcical
and the political system in scotland has
clearly
broken down and therefore not only are
you not getting a
second referendum there will have to be
elements of direct rule
from westminster reintroduced on things
like the electoral system
on things like the auditing of
the books all of that's coming up over
the next three hours
professor sir john curtis will have
crunched the numbers
and if he's listening to me now he'll
have some idea
of the kind of questions i am going to
ask him and we've got paul running now
will alex salmond hold the balance of
power
after the may election in the scottish
parliament
a yes b no c
plague on both houses you can vote now
on my twitter feed at george galloway
but that's not the only subject of
course we'll be discussing
tonight pretty patel pretty by name
sometimes not so pretty by nature is
britain's home secretary the very
first home secretary of asian
origin that britain has ever had
but she doesn't exactly roll out the
welcoming mat
for immigrants like her and her
family she has a set of new immigration
proposals that we'll be discussing with
former
conservative mp keith best
keith best was once a coming man in the
conservative party but since leaving
parliament
has devoted himself to the race
relations
industry and the whole issue
of immigration and its fairness or
otherwise we'll be talking to him second
in the show this evening we'll be
talking to
francesca nant who is a travel
expert and a very fine woman who runs a
blog that i myself
have appeared on and which is uh pretty
much the most popular
travel blog in the land because of
course
summer is coming might even be here
tomorrow
if the weather forecasts are right and
with summer
come itchy feet people will be looking
to
travel i know i will i'll definitely be
looking
to travel but can i to where can i
travel
what happens when i get there what
happens when i get back
because all kinds of places
are still in a third wave
of the coronavirus and we'll be talking
as always
to moats medic doctor physician surgeon
dr ranjit brah about the progress
of the vaccination roller the deadliness
or
otherwise that faces us from europe
boris johnson said today that uh
a third wave that is raging in europe
might well cross the channel three weeks
from now
if it does will our vaccinations be
enough
to save us dr br knows the doctor will
see you
in the third hour so get voting on my
poll
will alex salmond hold the balance of
power
after the may election in the scottish
parliament
a yes b no c
a plague on both their houses that's me
how about you i'll be right back
radio sputnik
[Music]
oh jack lover could you do us a favor
could you give that sue in there a
trimmer carries brought it in it needs a
right mop cut off
now then little boy is too ready
sputnik has been launched to give you a
closer look at everything happening in
the world
radio sputnik telling the untold
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
will alex salmon hold the balance of
power after the may election a yes
22 no 35
c plague on both our houses 43
get voting now if one man
in the whole country knows better than
my next guest professor sir john curtis
i'm a dutchman he is the diane or
political scientist
the psyphologist supreme strathclyde
university
is his bailiwick about the world is his
oyster
professor sir john thank you for
joining us again this evening let's
start with the alba
if we can uh everyone's saying
now john that well they knew this was
coming it was the most
uh predictable uh event uh
that there that could be imagined but i
didn't predict it and i get the
impression
uh from the rather headless chicken way
that the snp leaders uh at first
reacted that they weren't expecting it
either
what about you well we certainly knew
that there would be an attempt to run
a party list with a view to try to
persuade
people to vote for the smp for this
party
on the list vote instead of voting for
the smp for reasons we can go into if
you want in a moment
um dave thompson the former uh smp msp
set that party up
back in the autumn indeed it was all
ready to fight the election under i
think rightly the ban of alliance for
uh independence so the other the
stratagem that alex salmon has decided
to lead was a strategy
that was widely known there had been
some suggestions
for quite a while that maybe mr summoned
would
join mr thompson's set up but
uh in the end he's not decided to he's
decided to strike on his own so
the father something like this was going
on within the nationalist movement was
pretty widely known but you're right we
certainly didn't know
whether or not mr summit would be the
person who would end up leading him
now i laid out uh three possible there
may be more than three
three possible outcomes from this one
that
the two wings uh or two cheeks
of the same backside as some of us would
have it
of the nationalist movement will eat
each other
damage their cause and therefore
both fail a second is that
a super majority of msps
is obtained uh albeit
on a very much lower share of the vote
and the third is that the whole affair
so
discredits the process that it ends up
strengthening boris johnson's
refusal to grant a second referendum
these were the three eye canvas you may
have others professor
well the three you suggest are certainly
important and they're all three
possible outcomes of this process i
would simply add a
fourth because i think this then takes
us to the heart of the debate that's
been going inside the nationalist
movement at least so far as
the tactics for the election is
concerned which is that
mr salmond might fail to pick up very
much he doesn't add
uh or create a super majority
but along the way he does just well
enough
to deny the smp uh the chances of being
able to get an overall majority
on their own because although mr salmond
is right and it's you know the heart of
all of this you have to understand a
little bit about the scottish electoral
system
we have an electoral system in scotland
whereby 73 msps
are elected directly in the
constituencies
but then there are another uh
56 which are elected from party lists in
each of eight regions
but these list msps are allocated via a
proportion representation formula
such that the total number of msps both
constituency
and list is as proportionate as possible
to
uh the outcome on the list vote now what
this could mean and it certainly
this is what happened to the smp back in
2016 in the last election
it can mean that if you do really really
well in the constituencies
um you end up with so many constituency
msps
that the the proportional uh calculation
says ah you've already got your justice
zones maybe indeed you've got more than
your
just deserves proportion and therefore
you're not going to get more
uh list msps even though the you may be
way way ahead
on the list to vote and that therefore
the argument has been within the
nationalist movement
that in order to overcome this we
basically we should game the system
by creating a separate party
and running it only on the list
persuading people to vote for the smp on
the constituency
but for this other party on the list and
that indeed you know
that's exactly what exxon was trying to
do nothing new by despite this by the
way
there were a lot of suggestions back in
the days when the labour party dominated
scottish politics
that perhaps the co-op party should be
used in order to
create a separate list party this is
basically trying uh
to gain the system now although the smp
for the most part doesn't seem to
reliant on this msps and given where the
polls right at the moment
are unlikely to be picked up very much
in the way of list msps
the polls are just at that point
where the smp might still pick up two or
three list msps most obviously
in the south of scotland or in the
highlands
and those two or three could just be
critical
to the s p getting the overall majority
so here we get that
we come into an argument about which is
going to matter more to boris johnson
assuming either of them transfers
is boris johnson going to be more likely
to feel that he needs to give way when
there is a super majority
achieved by gaming the electoral system
um even though that super majority it
consists of msps from what in the system
to be three parties
the smp the greens and uh uber
or would he be more concerned about the
smp having an overall majority on their
own uh which in which instance
then the precedent of 2011
might be regarded as somewhat pressing
for the unions because in 2011 the smp
got an overall majority
and in the wake of that david cameron
then paved the way for the 2014
referendum
so it depends on which you think is the
more
important objective to be achieved so
far as the nationalist movement is
concerned but i mean that said of course
that's the narrow calculation you're
right the big calculation
is what does all of this do for support
for independence in the first place now
one direction i could say to look well
actually you know support for
independence is about 50 percent it's
been pretty solidly there for quite a
while now
i need about 87 of the people who are in
favor of independence are currently
minded to vote for the smp
that's looks like a something that's not
necessarily going to be unstudied by a
spat between uh mr sturgeon uh miss
sturgeon and mr summer
um but you know there's no guarantee of
that and undoubtedly
the crucial advantage that the
nationalist movement have had here the
two in scotland
is that it was effectively united the
smp basically
was the only party for the most part
representing nationalism in scotland
albeit with a bit of an appendage for
the greens in contrast
the unionists are seriously divided we
saw this again
in the last 24 hours douglas ross the
scottish conservative leader
putting out a call to label the
democrats let's get together
suggesting perhaps that indeed they
should be trying to gain the system by
colluding
and coming to your son for an actual
part well that got rebuffed pretty
quickly
and the you know the unionists are are
divided they don't agree about what
their tactics should be etc etc
so what we've now got on the nationalist
movement in a sense is now
uh that unity is is at risk of being
fractured and there's a disagreement
about the tactics so uh
to that extent at least alexander's
challenge certainly takes away one of
the strategic advantages or at least
puts at risk one of the strategic
advantages the nationalists currently
have north of the border
just to illustrate uh one of your
earlier points there in 2003
in central scotland labor got 106 000
votes on the regional list and gained
zero seats because they had done so well
in the constituencies whereas the old
age pensioners party
got a seat with 17 000 votes
and the scottish socialist party with
alba's
newest recruit tommy sheridan uh
agassi on 19 000.
this makes the point doesn't it about
the danger of
voting uh both votes snp
both votes tori both votes labor
oh yeah i mean there is there is no
doubt that um
that's precisely the scenario that uh
alex salmon is pointing to
and that indeed if given now nowadays
the conservative labor party
are primarily dependent on lift seats
then if alex simon were to succeed
against securing representation he would
probably gain more of those seats at the
expense
of the opposition parties than he would
the smp though in truth what you're
doing when you're doing this
you have to guess which party is going
to be the party that would otherwise get
the seventh seat that you might
otherwise pick up and that can often be
very difficult to calculate
and the point i just come back to yes in
six of the regions at the moment in
scotland
um the calculation that mr simon is is
is making does
it say is quite pressing but there are
two other regions where it
doesn't there are two regions where the
snp
might well need uh the list vote might
well make a difference
and to that extent at least i guess if
mr summit were really trying to gain the
system to the maximum advantage of the
nationals movement as a whole
perhaps he might stand in six of the
eight regions but not stand in the two
where the smp
have a chance however maybe what's going
on here and you've alluded to this in
your
in your various alternatives maybe
what's going on here is that of course
mr salmon doesn't necessarily want
the snp to get an for majority because
of course if the smp
gets an overall majority then it will be
able to determine what tactics it
deploys vis-a-vis the uk government what
it tries to do if the uk government says
no to referendum etc
it will not have to accommodate the
greens and or mr summit
perhaps mr salmon actually really wants
to be in a situation with your set the
king maker
i.e somebody uh to whom ms sturgeon has
to look for support
in order to be able to win national
strategy now that's up to mr summon to
uh
uh deny or or otherwise whether or not
that's the case but
perhaps at least you can see why maybe
that's one of the reasons
why the snp are not very keen on his
strategy
the green party what i call the snp's
gardening section
uh as uh clinging to the snp like
moss on on a dike they are in a way the
first losers from alex hammond's
move aren't they because they only get
the
five seats they have in hollywood
because
snp supporters in the first vote
give them uh votes in the second
and salmond is likely to outgun them
don't you think
well yes and no george i think the
honest truth is that there's
there's a bit of a two-way traffic here
i.e that some of the people
who would vote for the greens if the
greens were to stand in their
constituency
vote for the smp because they can't vote
for the green so the truth is
i think the snp gets boosted in the
constituencies by the greens not
standing
uh where they don't and they did fight
three constituencies last time
and yes the greens do profit from the
fact that some people vote strategically
for them
that said however uh one interesting
piece of analysis that's going to
actually come out on my website tomorrow
uh does point out that the kind of
people
who are most likely to say that they'll
think favorably about mr salmon and the
truth is that's very much a minority of
voters in scotland
those voters tend to be at the more
socially conservative end
of the nationalist coalition they're
disproportionately people who voted
leave in the 2016 referendum and these
are not the kind of people who for the
most part
are inclined to vote for the relatively
socially progressive greens so you might
well find that actually
the people who are willing to vote for
mr summoned on the list vote
are not necessarily the same people who
are willing to vote tactically for the
greens
lastly and i'm grateful for your time uh
i said earlier that that salmon
so far has picked up the kind of rougher
trade the rough trade end of the
nationalist movement uh you may or may
not agree with that characterization
but how do you characterize the kind of
people who have gone
over to salmon and what kind of
level of defection do you expect
well i think that the truth is what
we're looking at are people
for the most part who've been pretty
well associated with like someone for a
while
um and their views uh and their previous
positioning reflects the
division that there has been within the
smp for some weeks or months there are
essentially two crucial issues
the first is do you trust miss sturgeon
to pursue
holding another referendum with the zeal
and the arda
and uh the resilience that you think is
necessary these are people
who are rather disenchanted by the fact
that back in march 2017
ms sturgeon called for another
referendum got the scottish phone to
vote for where
for one but then in the wake of the
outcome of the 2017
uk general election when the s p lost
seats then
marched uh troops back down again these
are people who think that at the end of
the day
miss sturgeon is more interested in
remaining first minister of scotland
then she is at pursuing independence so
that though they're impatient with her
the second uh issue that divides most
these people
are that they are the people who are
concerned about the scottish
government's proposals whereby uh
trans people particularly trans women
are able to
reassign their agenda uh on the basis of
their
identity they don't require anything in
the way of uh
medical evidence if you think that's
relevant at all uh for the fact that
they've changed their their gender
um and uh these are people who think
that this perhaps is a step too far and
is
in particular putting up risk the rights
that have been gained by some women
uh so that those are the two crucial
true divisions
and they also these also seem to be
people who perhaps are not
quite do not necessarily feel that
re-entering the european union is
necessarily
quite as important for an independent
scotland
uh certainly the smp thing so you know
these are these are the fault lines
these are fault lines that have been
nagging away at the s p for quite a
while
what mr salmond has done is to bring
this out in the open
what is less clear is just how many
people are
actually willing to defect to the party
to do this he's obviously going to pick
up
some i suspect however for the most part
you know this is a
relatively uh minority group within the
s p or at least
minority groups of always willing
actually to defect and certainly when
you look
at um snp voters
only about 16 percent think favorably of
mr summoned
over 90 percent of them think favorably
of miss sturgeon
forgive me i said last but if you will
answer me this one
why would a nationalist populist party
like the snp uh go off
that tangent that you have just able
described
for example their lists have to be
topped
by an ethnic minority or a disabled
person the gender recognition thing that
you talked about
the hate crime bill and so on these
these seem to cut across uh the
uh you might say tunnel vision that a
nationalist populist
uh coalition or normally
uh or would be expected normally to be
pursuing
well yes but i think you know this is a
reminder to us george
that um the smp has
always been a broad church when it comes
to anything other independence there are
people in the party who are on the
center right
who probably would be in the
conservatives but for their belief in
independence
and there are those who regard
themselves as social democrats equally
there are plenty of social liberals but
there are also
some social conservatives and certainly
when it comes to brexit for example
there has
always been a body of snp support that
has felt that what's the point of
liberating ourselves from london only to
put ourselves in chains from brussels
what we've seen with the snp in
government is that
that that set of issues you know it's uh
brexit it is trans rights indeed it is
aspects of the
of the hate crime bill that you
mentioned that begins to fracture the
coalition because when it comes to these
kinds of issues
the fact that you are not in favor of
independence doesn't necessarily mean to
say
that you agree with the stance that's
been taken by the snp government on
these other issues
professor sir john curtis as always
thanks for joining us
on the mother of all talk shows will
alex salmond hold the balance of power
yes 21 no 34
or a plague on both their houses 45
you can vote on my twitter feed let's
take a call
before the break jared is in
pennsylvania
but wants to talk about scotland wow
jared go ahead
uh yes hello tom i mean tom
i'm come on uh yes hello george um yeah
i want to talk about
scotland um so this
recent talk about independence is
a bit um interesting
um case because in america
we've also had a long history of
successionist movements and independence
movements
we know quite a bit about the american
civil war
but what most people don't also know is
that
we had states like rhode island that
almost
uh completely seceded
from america during the war of 1812
against
britain we have
large independence movements in oregon
and washington
and we have hawaii
and california and texas as well but
um the thing about scottish independence
that i don't
seem to really get is
um you're on a big
island and basically
they want to rebuild hadrian's wall
almost you know about hadrian's wall
and they're building it from the other
side this time
instead of it being built from rome this
time
um it's being built from um
edinburgh and um
it seems to be a divide and conquer
tactic almost
you know like divide up these big states
into smaller states
we see this in uh the soviet union you
see this in yugoslavia
the u.s deep state is trying to do that
in
china with uh xi jiang
and uh tibet and hong kong
you know all these uh chinese states
they're trying to break away from
so it really doesn't make any sense
other than
if you wanted i i see the hand of
the european union and all this well me
too
me too and bravo jared i couldn't put
that better
uh myself and i i won't try to but there
is no doubt at all in my mind that the
hand of the european union
and it's a historic relationship between
the
scottish nationalists and the germans
the founders of the snp were
collaborators with the germans the nazis
in 1934 indeed their leader their main
leader was
intern during the war collaborating
with germany against britain
now of course germany in 2021 is not the
germany
of 1934 and the snp
of 2021 is not the snp
of 1934 but there is no doubt at all
in my mind that the european union would
like to
punish britain for brexiting
and there are many people in the british
political
system and in the media perhaps
especially
in the media that hate brexit
so much hate boris johnson for
brexit so much that they
will even subconsciously if not
consciously
they will agony and punishment on
our country because we deserve it for
having decided
to leave the european union my position
is very clear and
always has been all of my life i'm
against the breakup of countries
and the idea of partitioning
a small island of english-speaking
people especially given the economic
situation
which i shall adam bray later courtesy
of a good friend of mine in the business
community
in scotland when you take it into
account it's actually an act of
political
suicide but i've got to take a 60-second
break
count them
radio sputnik
just like our segment this is the week
let me begin with things i'd never
see here's a cracker
i read the daily mail
every single morning over
my breakfast the crosswords are indeed
my favorite i was never
a member of parliament
in fact i've never even bought
it i don't like wearing hats
i'm more of a headband kind of man
don't believe me look at how i push my
glasses
on my face as i make a point
how i use my hands to emphasize it
further and you know i'm really hungry
when i go quiet i'll continue
nicholas sturgeon is my favorite member
of the crankies
this version of george galloway is the
property of france do
and was not meant for broadcast just
desolate sputnik has been launched to
give you a closer look at
everything happening in the world radio
sputnik
telling the untold
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
he's clever that simon i must say he is
very very clever
uh the pool uh 700 people have voted
salmon will he hold the balance of power
yes 19 no 33
and a plague on both their houses 48
you can vote until uh the final hour
actually when we'll have a second poll
on my twitter feed at george galloway
now
countries that refuse to take back
migrants
may lose visas under pretty patel's
new plan britain could block visas from
countries
that refused to take back failed asylum
seekers and criminals
in a tit-for-tat plan laid out yesterday
by the british home secretary pretty
patel the proposal is among
a range of levers the government is
considering
to increase the number of illegal
migrants
sent back it was included in a document
published by the home secretary that
outlined an
overhaul of asylum rules patel said the
changes were needed
to fix a system that was collapsing
under the pressure
of illegal routes fresh figures revealed
that the cost of the asylum system to
taxpayers
had risen to more than 1.3 billion
pounds
because of backlogs caused by legal
challenges one of the men undoubtedly
behind
many of these challenges is the former
conservative
member of parliament the redoubtable
keith best
who is the former chief executive of the
immigration
advisory service who joins me now keith
welcome back
uh thank you mother of all talk shows
let's talk about the tip for that first
how seemly did that seem to you
well it's uh not exactly very prudent to
do this at the time we're just having a
massive spat
with the rest of the eu as well and i
think it'll
it's going to go down like a lead
balloon i mean the idea that we would uh
impose extra visa controls on french
citizens if we found asylum seekers
coming through france and bearing in
mind that we can't actually return them
to france now because since leaving the
eu
we are no longer subject to the dublin 3
treaty
which enables us to return asylum
seekers
who could have claimed asylum in another
safe country
so we've lost that as a result of brexit
unless we're going to have a lot of
bilateral treaty agreements with
all these countries through which asylum
seekers travel that they will
accept out of the goodness of their
heart refused asylum seekers that we
choose
to send back to them then we're not
going to get anywhere
and can you seriously see any european
country right now
saying oh we'll help you britain don't
worry yes we'll we'll take back any
number of people you want to send back
to us
apart from anything else of course
there's the age-old problem that we've
always had
that many asylum seekers and it's not
because they've destroyed themselves
many of them don't have documents so
actually you can't prove
where they've come from you can't prove
which country
uh they're a national of uh and it
becomes very very difficult
well they're not going to agree these
european countries
for the reason you said but another
reason uh
these migrants want to come here
to britain they don't want to be in
france why is that
well i think first of all you have to
look at the widespread use of the
english as a second language so i mean
if you don't speak a word of french or
german
but you have a smattering of english why
would you want want to go to france or
germany
where you've got a whole new cultural
learning curve to
to get hold of the other thing is and
i'm
very proud of this and i don't think we
should see it as a demerit
britain still has the reputation abroad
of being a fair country where we have
the rule of law
where even ministers of the crown can
appear before the courts
and be chastised by them and told that
they're acting
illegally in very many countries around
the world
unlike germany and france we've got the
rule of law and we're fair
well they have the rule of law but
frankly i can tell you from
the uh the decades that i've been
involved in this business
going to france and saying that actually
the french authorities
have a fair asylum system is really
stretching credibility quite a long way
i mean my experience has been that the
french police
uh find people in one department and
take them straight to the border with
the next department and say
you claim asylum over there not here
mate we don't want you
and the fact that you know for years and
years
the french police in calais have been
raiding what was then the jungle or now
the camp
where many asylum seekers assemble they
give them a one-way ticket to paris
hoping they'll get rid of them and then
after a while of course they all filter
back again
france is not an exemplar of the way to
deal with asylum cases
so what can we do keith uh 1.3
billion pounds is a lot of taxpayers
money
uh there do seem to be boats arriving
unmolested by the french
on a daily basis what should be done
well what should be done is what we've
always called to be done
right through the days of the labor
government with a
faster firmer fairer policy which is not
dissimilar from
what's being said now by the home
secretary the trouble is
these are aspirations most of it is in
cloud cuckoo land
uh they they can't achieve it and the
history shows that what we should be
doing
is speeding up the asylum process
putting enough investment as caroline
notes
former immigration minister said only
recently we need to invest in the system
to make sure that we deal with asylum
claims
rapidly as quickly as we can determine
whether somebody
really is a genuine refugee under the
convention terms of definition of a
refugee or not
uh and if if they are to give them
settled status
which they're entitled to we are
signatory
to that convention uh they're entitled
to that if they're not
we then got to try to find ways of
getting them back
either to the country of origin or to
another country
i don't pretend that is easy for the
reasons you and i have just mentioned
why why would a country for example say
that they will take back people if we
can't even prove they're their nationals
i mean can you imagine the indian
government saying to britain
oh oh we've got a few people here who
claim to be indian
we'd like to send them back to you thank
you very much the indian government
would turn around straight away and say
first of all you prove they're our
nationals we don't know about them
yeah that i mean you you you posit
uh a possible alternative but when
examined even by
yourself it isn't an alternative so
what you're really saying is uh let's
ascertain who's entitled to it and give
it to them
more quickly uh and let's hold on to
those that aren't
entitled to it because we're not going
to be able to send them anywhere
in it anyhow no what what we've got to
do with the ones who fail
to satisfy the tests as to whether
they're genuine refugees or not
is to have a pan-european and frankly
a a global understanding about
sending people uh elsewhere it's no good
pretending as the home secretary as we
can dump them all
on the isle of man or the isle of jersey
or or something like that i mean
then they're not going to live with with
that kind of solution
we've got to do this through
international cooperation
and i'm afraid at the moment britain's
stock in international cooperation
with the the rest of the countries of
europe is frankly not very high
didn't pretty patel suggest the scottish
islands
uh as a destination caused a great deal
of horror in
scottish tori circles i think she
suggested
artney or shetland and and the hebrides
well we've probably all got our favorite
islands we can suggest
as to where they should go but frankly
it's not
it's not a solution uh you know they
they would still be within
the british domain and and clearly what
every home secretary whatever political
color they may wear
every home secretary has said is that
those who are not entitled to remain in
this country
should not be here that's a perfectly
understandable
and legitimate position to take they
shouldn't be here
but once they've got here trying to get
rid of them is a very different
uh situation i mean i years and years
ago george
i was involved with the vietnamese
refugees i went out to hong kong
i saw the camps there i mean at the end
of the day after the rest of the
countries had taken their pick
of all the chinese nationals and the
entrepreneurs and
everything like that the hong kong
government was left with the
basic ethnic vietnamese whom nobody
wanted
and they had to ultimately assimilate
them into their society
because no other country would take them
now the only way you're going to deal
with that
is to actually have a proper
pan-european
agreement and frankly uh you know
although i'm very pro-european
i i acknowledge right at the outset
that europe has failed miserably in
having a comprehensive
common asylum system it's all been
nimbyism not in my backyard thank you
very much
let's push them somewhere else that is
not the way to deal with human beings
and it's certainly not the way to deal
with international diplomacy and
politics
keith best thank you very much indeed
you look like you're well suntanned
i hope you're resting up somewhere very
nice thank you
george thank you for joining us will
alex salmond
hold the balance of power after the may
election yes 19 is falling
no 33 also falling and the plague on
both their houses
up three at 48 you can vote
on my twitter feed now in the
uh second hour we're going to be talking
to
lisa francesca nand who is a
travel journalist and host of the big
travel podcast on the coronavirus impact
on the travel industry and travel
this summer but let's squeeze a call in
before the news
it's michelle in slow on the immigration
issue michelle welcome hello george how
are you this evening
and the better for hearing your dulcet
tones welcome back
go ahead okay uh well um
many many years ago i used to work for
pittman's training and i think it was
when the government cancelled something
called
individual learning accounts now
these individual learning accounts meant
that everybody
in the uk had what i think was around
300 pounds
that they could use for things like it
training now
pitmans as you know have been going a
very long time
and we were relying on people's
individual learning accounts to provide
teacher-led
training we and our
franchise was completely and utterly
killed off when they brought in
uh learn direct individual this was the
blair government i remember it well i
was there
right well you know what happened they
cancelled
every person in the uk
individual learning accounts
possibilities to retrain in it
with real teachers and then they
replaced it
with english as a second
language and this massive online
training thing
called learn direct that was a complete
and utter failure
but that was 300 pounds of
training funds out of the pockets of
every single person in the uk
yeah uh it's been mishandled for a very
long time hasn't it
um it's nothing to do with race because
uh
of course uh there are very substantial
numbers of people legally uh here and
they've had children grandchildren even
great-grandchildren
from other races and have contributed
mightily magnificently to the patchwork
that is
the united kingdom but every country
needs immigration controls only
trotskyites and liberals
favor a world with no immigration
controls
and so we now are in the business
of uh of giving people points the
so-called
australian points-based system so we can
choose the immigrants like keith bess
was talking about with the chinese
entrepreneurs from vietnam choose the
immigrants that are best
placed to contribute well to our
economic development
for the benefit of everybody uh
but the the vast majority i'd say this
as someone who sat
in surgeries as a member of parliament
for almost
30 years the vast majority
of asylum seekers do not qualify
under the asylum conventions they are
not specifically personally
uh at risk or fear of persecution
they are effectively economic refugees
though
many of them are fleeing from wars
that we and other countries visited upon
them and their countries and i
don't put them in second place because
of that my own grandparents
i came here as as economic refugees so
i'm the last person to dis uh an
economic refugee
and who knows god forbid i might end up
an economic refugee somewhere
sometimes someplace myself but we ought
to confuse that
with asylum policy michelle should we
absolutely not but um i mean
one of the things that we're talking
about here is we are actually
not looking at the economic backgrounds
of these people that are coming
into england to
learn english basically to
our expense and then one of the
reports that i actually read on was the
people crossing europe coming here
using easl funding to learn english
with the objective actually getting into
oh america all right michelle i mean i
don't know
you know i i it was just a report that i
read at the time i found quite shocking
good luck trying to get into america joe
biden's
deporting people from america uh even
faster
than donald trump did michelle and slo
thanks for that wonderful call here's
the news
with jamie law
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news the british
government remains confident everyone in
the uk will get a second dose of the
covert vaccine
within 12 weeks of their first the
culture secretary has said
questioned about the concerns over
vaccine supply
oliver dowden said we always knew there
would be ups and downs
adding that the timetable was on track
he said it was essential
to provide second doses and it would not
require mixing vaccines
dowden added that the modern jab was due
to arrive in the uk in
april it's the third vaccine of seven
that the uk has put in an order for
and the country has lined up to receive
17 million doses
so far more than 30 million uk adults
have received their first coronavirus
vaccine from either the pfizer
or the oxford jabs and more than 3
million of them
have had a second but vaccine supply
issues
have continued to make the rollout bumpy
earlier this month the nhs warned of a
significant reduction in jabs
available in england in april and there
has been a delay to oxford astrazeneca
shipments from
india there are also tensions from the
eu over the supply of jabs
low drivers cabin crew prison escorts
and seasonal workers entering
england from outside the uk will need to
take a covert 19 test within 48 hours of
arrival
the government has said those remaining
in the uk for longer than two days will
be required to take a further test
every three days the new regime is
intended to stop the virus spreading
and new variants entering the new rules
take effect from the 6th of april
mp neil hanvey has become the second one
to defect from the snp to join
alex salmond's new pro scottish
independence party
alba the mp for kirk caldey and
cowden beath said that alba provided
quote a tonic
for our movement on saturday former
justice secretary kenny mccaskill
announced he would also stand as a
candidate for alba alex salmond launched
the party on friday
with the aim of building quote a super
majority for independence
at hollyrood after the election in may
suez canal salvage teams are alternating
between dredging
and tugging as they continue to try to
dislodge the massive container ship
blocking the busy waterway dredges have
so far shifted 27
000 cubic meters of sand to a depth of
18 meters with work set to continue
around the clock
the 400 meter long ever given became
jammed
diagonally across a southern section of
the canal in high winds more than five
days ago
halting shipping traffic in one of the
world's busiest waterways as of
yesterday 321 boats were waiting to get
through the canal including dozens of
container ships bolt carriers and oil
tankers
airstrikes that sent villagers fleeing
into the jungle show the situation in
myanmar is much
worse a humanitarian worker has said as
military leaders reportedly partied on
the deadliest day of violence since last
month's coup
more gunfire has been reported today as
people gathered for the funeral of one
of at least 114 people said to have been
killed by security forces yesterday
including a five-year-old boy and a
13-year-old girl
local media is reporting that around 3
000 people from
south eastern current state have left
the country and crossed the border into
thailand
to escape the violence
despite the bloodshed protesters
returned to the streets today to demand
a return
to democracy david eubank founder of the
humanitarian group free burma rangers
said airstrikes on a village in karen
killed at least
three people and wounded eight others he
said the first airstrike struck around 8
30 pm local time on saturday
and moore hit between 1am and 2am today
two top u.n officials condemned
myanmar's military junta today
in a joint statement today alice warimu
and derek ii
un special adviser on the prevention of
genocide and michelle bachelet
un high commissioner for human rights
urged the myanmar military to
immediately stop killing the very people
it has a duty to serve and protect
a suspected suicide bomb attack outside
a catholic church in the indonesian city
of makassar
has left 14 people wounded police say an
explosion erupted as two attackers tried
to enter the church on palm sunday the
first day of easter
a destroyed motorbike and body parts
were found at the scene and police said
the two attackers had died
militant islamists have attacked
churches in the past but no group has
yet
said it was behind the bombing
indonesia's president joko widodo
condemned the act
as a terror attack facebook has frozen
venezuelan president
nicolas maduro's page after he claimed
without evidence that a herbal remedy
could cure covert 19.
he said in january that a time herb
solution could cure the disease
he will be unable to post for 30 days
the company said the leader has
repeatedly violated its policies on
coronavirus disinformation
maduro is not the only world leader to
face a ban from social media companies
over kovid
u.s president donald trump and brazil's
jaya bolsonaro have also faced action
over covert posts
and finally a six-year-old boy has found
a fossil dating back
millions of years in his garden after
receiving a fossil hunting kit for
christmas
siddhak singh jamaat known as sid said
he was excited to find the fossil in his
garden in warsaw
after digging for worms his father vish
singh was able to identify the horn
coral
through a fossil group he is a member of
on facebook the group identified the
find as most likely a rugosa coral
estimated to be between 251 and 488
million years old
sing senior said quote the period that
they existed was from between
500 million and 251 million years ago
the paleozoic era england at the time
was part of pangaea a landmass of
continents
england was all underwater as well
and that's the latest here on sputnik
news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
vote now on my twitter feed will alex
salmond hold the balance of power in
scotland
after the may election yes no or a
plague on both their houses
we'll be taking calls after my next
guest
and so get your calls in now if you're
in the uk
it's 02077-982-2555
zero one seven five seven seven four
four four four eight zero or you can
tweet us
of course at george galloway at rt uk
news
uh mandais says george how do you feel
about
vaccine passports we'll discuss that
maybe in the third hour
mandate and in response to the poll
karen
says i really hope to god not even more
frightening
is tommy sheridan has joined the alba
gang i fear dark times ahead for
scotland well it might get on the swing
vote if you get my drift
ivan says sturgeon and salmond should
meet on ranach moore
with their best claymores fight to the
death i'd buy a ticket to watch
and derek says i'm sure more will jump
ship
after the election and sturgeon will be
on the outside
looking in and martin says independence
is an irrelevant
distraction from scottish institutional
uh favor so get your votes in on the
polls
get your calls in lisa francesca
nand is not just a travel journalist
she's not any travel journalist she's
the doyan
of travel journalists and host of the
big travel podcast
on which i have appeared myself and she
joins us now to discuss travel in the
age
of the coronavirus you're looking
wonderful it's great to
see you again uh lisa tell us
uh in a nutshell are any of us
going to be taking a holiday abroad
this summer if so where and what will
the consequences be
i it's a guess at the moment if i'm
honest i'd like to to come on here and
pretend i know everything but it is an
absolute guess because things are so
changeable
the government this week have been
talking about the traffic light system
where you've had green countries there
will be no restrictions
maybe a requirement to take a test amber
countries will be open with quarantine
and red countries which will be just be
no go or
or a hotel quarantine as we've got with
the red list at the moment
but you know we did travel last year we
traveled last year the travel corridors
were a little bit of a mess admittedly
uh people were stuck in other countries
and wanted to get back
and hearing that be a quarantine and
rushing to get back but
last year we didn't have the vaccine and
we did travel so i am very very
hopeful that this year we will travel i
think it it very much depends on your
personal risk-taking ability you know
can you afford to spend a few grand on a
holiday at the risk that you might not
be able to take that holiday
that you might not get that money back
for months and months can you personally
afford to take the risk that when you
get back you'll have to
possibly quarantine for 10 days
therefore taking
10 days off school or 10 days off work
it all depends on it on
very personal reasons but you know
george there's so many people that want
to travel at the moment and there's a
lot of people that say it's a global
pandemic we shouldn't be traveling
but there's so many people that have had
a really really tough year and they
think
travel is part of what i do it's it's my
holiday i need to go away and relax and
i don't think we should holiday shame
them
and also we live in such an
international community that there's
also people trying to get
back to places they love people they
love people that are trying to get into
this country as well
you know we talk about holidays and
people can be a bit flippant about it
but travel is about so much more than
holidays
for many people too yes absolutely
there are a couple separated families
separated
there are people uh like myself with
property
overseas that i haven't seen for more
than a year i hope it's still standing
uh there are all kinds of reasons to
travel but
the most important one for me is to sit
on a deck chair
in the in the sun and i'm wondering
you see i i've had the uh vaccination
therefore if the vaccination works that
means
nobody can give it to me doesn't mean i
can't give it to them but it means they
can't give it to me
uh why is it so difficult to get
reciprocal
agreement with countries like spain like
portugal
i think that the vaccine what you're
kind of referring to there is a vaccine
passport and it's controversial because
the people who haven't had the vaccine
if there is some sort of reciprocal
agreement would not be able to travel
although the eu met last week to try and
discuss what would happen with a
potential vaccine passport and they did
say
that actually they're going to hopefully
have a digital
certificate a digital health certificate
which will either prove you've had the
vaccine
or prove you've had a negative test so
it's not going to be just exclusive to
people
who uh who have the vaccine which is a
good thing although there are private
companies
already saga and some of the airlines
have said
saga cruises pno cruises and some of the
airlines have said
you know and it's their prerogative as
well to say that actually we will only
be accepting vaccinated people
which does seem a little bit unfair
because i'm unable to have the vaccine
at the moment for due to my age i'm too
young finally for something
um but you know there will be cases
where countries will accept us
based on the negative test as well and
interestingly you've got this dual thing
going on you've got the eu meeting to
sort of uh you know
do something together and also
individual countries are coming out
greece has said they'll accept people
that have been vaccinated spain have
said something similar
turkey have said something similar as
well from from the middle of may
the thing is that the uk they're not
letting us go now you know the countries
are saying please come in we need your
money
and now our government has said actually
you can't travel it's now illegal to go
abroad on holiday and you'll be charged
5 000 pounds
um what we what we're hoping for is by
the 12th of april
we'll have some news on this but um you
know as these things go we'll probably
get some news leaked before
um but but who knows but that's what
we're looking at the moment i think
the people who really want to travel
will go we'll probably have a traffic
light system and we probably will have
some sort of vaccine passport so you'll
be all right george so that that's okay
for you
i'm so old i'm all right i've got the uh
vaccination
but you mentioned cruises there lisa
aren't cruises done for uh
after all that was the outbreaks on
board
ships and so on it's hard to see how
cruisers make a comeback
i wouldn't get on a big ship with
hundreds of people and be
trapped as it were on it with the risk
of
substantial outbreak of the virus yeah i
see
i do really see where you're coming from
with that but people who love cruises
really love cruises and there'll be
people who are absolutely desperate to
get on cruises right now
and they are you know traditionally the
older generation and they will have had
the vaccine so i think
you and i might not necessarily be
interested in a cruise but people there
are people who are desperate to get on a
cruise and we've said this before with
cruises haven't we people call them
giant floating petri dishes because uh
there's been issues with the norovirus
and other illnesses
even before the covert situation but i
think you know if we can travel this
year i think that would be a lot of
people interested in cruises
if we can't travel this year i think
we're in grave danger of not just
cruise companies but massive companies
airlines and
people that provide hundreds of
thousands of jobs you know you think of
the travel industry i think we're in
grave danger of them
uh going bust so i really do hope from a
financial point of view as well as you
know i want to get
on holiday as as much as the next person
i think that from a financial point of
view we really need to start travel
not just about us going away which is
lovely but about people coming into this
country and that's something we forget
when we talk about travel during the
corona virus is that we need people in
this country
we need people on the airlines in the
hotels at the tiny little tea rooms and
restaurants and the museums and the
art galleries and the fish and chip
places you know we need people to come
here too
quite so uh on that uh staying at home
staycation i saw an item today uh that
you can't buy a camper van at the moment
in britain
for love nor money because uh the demand
for them has gone through the roof as
people calculate that they may well be
staycationing uh to what extent
does our holiday infrastructure
in britain in the coastal communities
for example
uh in the highlands in the lake district
to what extent can it cope with a
massive increase
in staycations i don't necessarily think
there will be
there is obviously an increase in
staycations but without the people
coming into this country i think that
will cancel each other out but
in terms of people who want to to get a
holiday in the uk
it's actually really difficult i've been
trying to book something and it's
actually really difficult
and also you know i love the uk i
absolutely all the places you mentioned
are absolutely beautiful stunning
probably some of the best places in the
world
if you could guarantee the weather but
they're also really really
expensive for normal families it's
it's a lot cheaper to go to turkey or
greece or the costa del sol it's a lot
cheaper to
buy a glass of wine or an ice cream or
the hotel or anything else when you're
there so
actually for a lot of um already a lot
of for a lot of normal families
holidaying in this country is actually
out of reach and
you're right you know staycations have
been booked and booked and booked and
actually
it's not easy for people to actually
book something so
if you can't go abroad and you can't go
here it looks like you're
you're not having a holiday at all even
the campsites are booked up you know and
it's not
very easy to go wild camping too so it
is it is a great shame for a lot of
people that want to go traveling and
that's a
another big reason i'm not just saying
this because i am part of the travel
industry and i'm desperate to go away
myself but
that's another big reason we need to get
travel moving and lastly
uh what has it meant for i mean how do
you
be a travel writer when there ain't no
travel uh
you are uh you are the as i say the
doing of this
business but is anyone still paying
attention and
is there anything still to write and
talk about
well i'm really lucky in the way that
travel news is travel news so i've
actually been really busy i class myself
as simon cold as unofficial
understudy obviously i don't know as
much as him he's you know
he he is the god but no you're right
nobody is going anywhere and
you know i've been reporting on the
travel i've been busier than ever but
the big travel podcast which of course
you have been on and been a wonderful
guest is about
interviewing people through their lives
through travel so it hasn't really
affected me
personally but i for me personally like
many people i'm desperate to get back
abroad and you've got family abroad the
same as i have you know
my i grew up in spain my parents are in
the costa del sol my best friends there
my
my best friends are having a birthday
party this week that i should be at and
you know for many people who have
property abroad there's many many people
who do that and have
friends and family you know i think that
is that that is the real thing it's
heart-wrenching to be separated from
them
i'm not taking away from also george
it's ha it's heart-wrenching for people
who are separated
from their friends and family within the
country you know i realized that and i
think
you know we need to get things moving we
need to do it safely obviously i'm no
you know anti-vaxxer or covert denial we
need to do it safely but we we need to
do it we need to get
back human contact and social
interaction whether that's
within this country or abroad as well
lisa nan thank you for joining us on the
mother of
all talk shows that's lisa francesca
nand
travel journalist and podcaster let me
take
another of those 60 second breaks you
can count them
radio sputnik
[Music]
we are above all the latest developments
and we don't
take any sides radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
want to know how international fishers
fit into local ones and how local issues
fit into
international ones with the historical
context
to tie them together we're bringing it
to you all by
any means necessary tune in weekdays
from
2 to 4 p.m eastern standard time to hear
me
jackie lukman alongside my co-host sean
blackman
by any means necessary your guide to
connecting the social
political and economic movements shaping
the world around us
you're listening to radio sputnik
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
now this is where i look back at what
was in the news and making the headlines
over these
seven days of our checkered history this
is
the week on this day in 1939 the spanish
civil war ended
when madrid fell to the fascists headed
by
general francisco franco and on the
same day 40 years later in 1979
radioactive steam leaked into the
atmosphere
in pennsylvania usa it happened when a
water pump broke down
at three mile island nuclear plant ten
miles southeast
of the state capital harrisburg the
accident was caused by a combination
of human error and equipment failure and
the plant
was partially shot down three mile
island
remains the largest nuclear incident
in us history apart from hiroshima
and nagasaki of course in june
sorry in 1971 u.s army lieutenant
william kelly
was found guilty in a court martial of
the me lie
massacre where 500 south vietnamese
villagers
men women and children who looked much
like my own children
were murdered by soldiers under his
command
his sentence of course was condemned
three years
of house arrest and in 1971
charles manson and three members of his
hippie cult were sentenced to death in
los angeles they were found guilty
of the august 1969 murders
of seven people and one unborn child
at the beginning of the year their
victims included eight months
pregnant actress sharon tate wife of the
film director
roman polanski the california supreme
court
abolished the death penalty in 1972 and
the four
were given life sentences instead
spinning back more than a century from
that in 1867
the united states bought alaska
from russia for just over seven million
dollars
working out at roughly two cents an
acre the worst land deal any russian
ever made and the film chariots of fire
directed by
shu hudson and starring ben cross and
ian charlson
premiered in 1982. it was a winner
a year before in 1981 president ronald
reagan
was shot and wounded in washington by
john hinckley
afterwards he's said to have commented
to his good wife nancy
shucks i forgot to duck security at the
british parliament was virtually
non-existent
in 1979 at the height of the troubles
in northern ireland when shadow northern
ireland secretary
the conservative grande aerie neve was
killed by a car bomb
as he drove out of the house of commons
car park
i must have driven up out that car park
a thousand times maybe more and every
time i did
i wondered if my car was going to meet
the same faith that his did it was a
tilt
mechanism bomb and as he mounted the
slope it triggered the explosion
this was also the week in 1951 that the
rosenbergs
an american electrical engineer and his
wife
were found guilty by new york's federal
court of passing
atomic secrets to the ussr julius
rosenberg age just 33 and his 35 year
old wife ethel
were accused of stealing technical
information
from the atomic research center in los
alamos
and turning over to the kgb the
rosenbergs were sentenced to death
but unlike the family and the charles
manson group
their death sentence despite numerous
appeals for clemency
was executed they were killed in the
electric chair
at sing-sing prison on the 19th of june
1953 leaving two small children as
orphans they were the only people in the
united states
ever executed for cold war espionage
and their conviction fueled u.s senator
joe mccarthy's
anti-communist crusade against
un-american
activities by u.s citizens
and i certainly can't forget this one
this the most sensational
result in british by-election history
bar none represents
the bradford spring this is an
uprising amongst thousands of people
many of them young people never involved
in the political process
before who have demonstrated in this
mammoth majority this mammoth
vote a total rejection
of the three major parties on the
british political
scene i care nothing
for the conservatives or the liberal
democrats i wish them
political perdition but i do care
about the labour party in which i served
for 37 years
for 18 of which as a labour member of
parliament
well now of course i care nothing about
any of the three of them
but i certainly can't forget that night
it was on the 29th of march
in 2012 that i won the bradford west
parliamentary seat from labor
by an astonishing margin of 10 140
votes i said then that it was the most
sensational victory
in by-election history and indeed it was
it was a total rejection of the big
three political parties
it was a swing almost unprecedented and
absolutely unprecedented for a left-wing
alternative to the three major
parties it was an astonishing week
because two days later still wearing
that crumpled coat
because i didn't have time to go back to
london
and pick up a better one i was at the
altar with my good wife
gayatri two days later we got married me
still in my campaign close in 1920
the british parliament accepted irish
home rule
a civil war in ireland followed
harold wilson's labour party in 1966
won a landslide victory in the general
election
the party had a majority of 96
seats and did so little of note
with that gigantic almost unprecedented
labor
majority that just four years later in
they fell from office and power
landed in the lap of edward
heath which wasn't um all that
comfortable place to be
labor lost popularity when it devalued
the pound
in november 1967. plans for trade union
reform
had to be shelved and france vetoed
britain's second application
for membership of the common market
last week the seattle sounders
professional football team or
soccer as they like to call it across
the pond unveiled the second
shirt commemorating jimi hendrix
complete with purple haze
and jimmy's signature on it this was the
week
in 1967 that he first set fire
to his guitar at a london gig
difficult odd segway that but people may
have thought it was
an april fool's joke when on april the
1st in 1978
steve wozniak and steve jobs founded
apple computer in the garage of jobs
parents house in cupertino california
it is now the largest company in the
world but
is it is it larger i ask my clever
friends through the glass
is it larger than amazon if someone
could uh
check that for me anyway who could
forget certainly not me that it was in
2017 that bob dylan received
his nobel prize for literature at a
private ceremony
in stockholm well deserved a long
overdue
bob dylan is the greatest writer in the
english language
since william shakespeare discuss
in 2001 former yugoslav president
slobodan milosevic
was arrested and taken to prison ending
a heavily armed standoff
at his belgrade villa after u.s pressure
milosevic was extradited to the hague to
face an
international criminal tribunal he died
in his cell at the u.n tribunal in march
2006 of a heart attack
and in 1982 several thousand argentine
troops
seized the falklands from britain it was
of course to lead to the falklands war
and britain's recapturing of the islands
the 2 300 people and the millions of
sheep
they're on and finally i read during the
week that the band
fleetwood mack you probably didn't know
they were still on the go
are to embark on another tour and they
want
everyone who was ever in the band to
take part in it
i counted 20 until i ran out of fingers
and toes and
that doesn't of course include the
founder of the late and great peter
green
it'll have to be a double decker tour
bus but it was
in this week in 1977 that their
album rumors went to number one and
stayed there
for 31 weeks it was so good
one got bored of it it was on so much
that's it then
another turbulent seven days and that
was the week
that was here's malcolm on the line in
glasgow
go ahead malcolm hi george thanks for
taking the call
um a little bit unhappy that israel just
took the lead against scotland one
minute ago
oh really really well they're always
very close games
yeah they're good team israel it's nice
to see those crowds in the stadiums
there i think they've had the
vaccinations most of them i had mine
today yeah they have
uh they've vaccinated more or less
everybody uh the uae
is the second highest percentage of
people vaccinated
and britain is the third not bad for us
yeah i think it's a good way out uh
george i just very quickly i'll give you
a back story i hope you're familiar with
it so you can watch lyrical on it if you
are familiar with it
okay for those viewers listening is that
scotland issued advice
that people should not travel more than
five miles and
specifically not to the highlands and
the islands where
you had an aging population that weren't
well served by hospitals so um
there was a small island in scotland
that had 170 residents mostly aging
and they'd set up a facebook page to say
to people you're not following that the
the guidance you should be in your
primary residence you should go home
and not threaten our our lives you know
as an old people
so there was a facebook page and they
were openly saying to people you should
go home
now i don't know how to say this but
there was a
a government advisor of the snp who two
days before
this came out officially moved to an
island
of 170 people with his family
now you have to think he's had a heads
up and he knows that he should do that
so he did it two days before the
official announcement came out
so when this 70 year old man who suffers
from diabetes
was saying to people you should go home
and you should leave us
you know leave us and to be safe the
police finally arrived at his door he
thought finally they're taking
action and they come to interview me
about these people who shouldn't be here
now the police who basically galvanized
themselves to go to an island
are basically now calling him a racist
and they're calling him as an aggressive
person because he had a conversation
with the wife
of a government advisor who was passing
by his house and he said you should go
home
and because of the wife in question was
from originally from zimbabwe and
and black she called him a racist and he
had six months of
legal fees and of of being accused of
being a racist
and that was am i correct in thinking
that the
the police sit in the the the cabinet
with the
scottish parliament and who sent these
police officers to this 70 year old man
to say correctly you're not following
guidance go home
and under my final point george is under
the hate crime law now
he would have been found guilty he was
found not guilty on all charges in
auburn
uh recently and this is just a disgrace
it's another salmon
witch hunt disgrace from the snp
government
of course he's not guilty of that
particular crime this is
entirely nicholas sturgeon and hamza
youssef's
hate crime law uh that is quite a
convoluted story you told me
i'm not sure i fully grasped it but i'd
i'd make sure the scottish newspapers
knew about
it because it has literally everything
it's got a government adviser and his
wife who's a zimbabwean
it's got a government minister who just
moved to an island
uh two days before he would not have
been
allowed to do so it's got people telling
other people to go home
uh it's got everything malcolm thanks
for bringing it to
our attention i didn't know any of that
sean is in lanarkshire
on craig murray uh breaking news is it
sean
i thought well hey i'm not too sure
about breaking news but
uh actually i don't think i don't think
we're going to get a
uh a sentence until the day after
the scottish parliament elections
actually which may or may not be
significant
well i suppose that you could look at
some of the dates and say that there
are some strange coincidences but if we
started looking at all the strange
coincidences in the dates
concerning the snp in recent years we
would
be here forever yeah um but george i'd
like to
highlight a a good friend of yours in
the shows craig murray's
play at the moment yeah um a voice to be
podcasted on recently and
and i saw a man who was suffering under
the weight of
obviously a lot of people's a malice
towards them and
in my opinion certainly my reading of
the case
um and i'd just like to help jenna do
this last thing to please support him
and
and like the work that he's doing and
subscribe um
he seems to be suggesting that he's
finding it difficult to
to write on his on his podcasts and
things just knowing well he's uh he's
afraid to in case he compounds
the uh the offense that has been
uh taken sean thanks for uh bringing
that
up uh craig ma i have uh absolutely
profound political differences with
craig murray
on the question of
breaking up britain but i absolutely
acknowledge his honorable
track record as a public servant as an
ambassador
as a civil servant and now as a
campaigner a few men or women
in this country have uh the
honor that craig murray deserves
he gave up effectively invited the
sack from the blair government and jack
straw
the then foreign secretary for
condemning the
use of torture and disappearance in
uzbekistan when he was
the british ambassador there he was
literally sacked for
and i quote over focusing on
human rights unquote remember that the
next time you hear the british
talking about other people's human
rights
craig murray was sacked as the british
ambassador
to uzbekistan for over focusing
on human rights and
since then craig murray has uh in the
most honorable
and eloquent way spoken out against one
crime after another most particularly
the iraq war which is where i came to
know him
best and he appeared uh most notably in
my
film the killings of tony blair if you
haven't seen that yet i commend it to
you
uh in my shop www.georgegalloway.shop
it's a film that everybody needs to see
and craig murray
plays a significant part in that
film craig murray has been found guilty
not by a jury but by the bench
in the scottish high court of
contempt of court while i who read
every word and twice every word
that he wrote throughout the whole
alex almond saga i would say that not
only
was he not guilty of contempt of court
he was guilty only of
over focusing on the importance of
justice
craig murray is an honorable man
and if he is sent to prison by the
scottish
justice system it will
compound the overwhelming feeling
amongst thinking people in scotland and
beyond
that there is something darkly deeply
rotten in the scottish judicial
system if craig murray at his age
his level of infirmity a man who has
been
giving everything he could to save
julian assange from dying in prison
may himself go to prison and be
at risk of death it would be a monstrous
travesty of justice if craig murray
was the only person to go to jail
as a result of the framing of alec
salmond now sometimes your water
tells you something and i just knew that
what my
editor said in that script i was reading
about that was the week was not right he
said that
apple was the biggest company in the
world in fact
it's the fifth biggest company in the
world here they are
walmart is the biggest company in the
world
worth 542
billion pounds the
china petroleum and chemical corporation
is the second biggest 355.8
billion pounds third is amazon which is
the one i thought was the biggest
that's what 321.8
billion pounds petro china
who knew that two of the top five
biggest companies in the world were
chinese
the petro china company limited is what
billion pounds and apple inc
in fifth place is 273.9
billion dollars all of those were
dollars did i say pounds
anyway uh let me give you the phone
numbers again if you're in the uk
or 2077 982 255
if you're in the u.s 0 0 one seven five
seven
seven four four four four eight
zero the poll is still running at least
for another fifteen minutes
will alex salmond hold the balance of
power
after the may elections yes 20 percent
of you that's up one
no 33 percent of you that's no change
c you wish a plague on both their houses
47 go to my twitter feed
right now at george galloway and
you can vote let me take a quick break
radio sputnik
call me come and have a go if you think
you're hard enough
don't bring up a false name come on air
call me and let's have this mata out
[Applause]
that's 2016's argument michael i'm no
longer
arguing with you about the merits of
brexit
i'm arguing with you about democracy
about the right of the majority
to have their decision their vote
implemented this match will get red hot
not have a referendum and let them sort
it out among themselves
robert i want a referendum let me put
that in capital letters
if you think this year which is shaping
up already
to be an honest miserables for the snp
if you think this is your year
go ahead come on let's have it out
but no george it's not as simple as that
right have you seen the documentary
about camera analytica and people who
work there
have you looked at this i'm not
interested in precisely
i'm not interested in them bruce because
it's all a red herring
just like russiagate was a red herring
do you only want to hear voices that
agree
with you because if you do you're not
clever enough to be at this
open university of the airwaves in fact
you need to go back to remedial
and learn something about what democracy
and freedom of speech actually mean
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have
as long as you have questions we'll keep
asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
let's go to hawaii who wouldn't
especially in this period where we can't
go
anywhere at all and hear from albert go
ahead albert
hi george how are you doing good lovely
to talk to you in
hawaii yes it's been a while um
i wanted to talk a little about what's
occurred with the suez canal
oh yeah you have that ship that's stuck
there yeah the reason why i wanted to
bring that up
is the impact on shipping um one of the
things that i've noticed i've noted this
recently
is i think to me there's a major problem
with um the size of container ships
for example yeah this uh evergreen one
is the size of
a new york skyscraper
yeah about the empire state building
yeah because they're building
more and more uh larger container ships
and what's happening is a lot of these
ports
they have to start dredging they have to
have all these dredging projects like
they do in miami
in the port of boston they've been
dredging like crazy more recently
to expand the ports and to expand that
and so when you look at what happened
with the swiss canal
apparently they wasn't enough dredging
for the ship
uh so the reason i bring this up is
it's part of the i think one of the big
problems in regards to
not only societies but the idea of
shipping is you have these gigantic
ships that are being built
as opposed to the past well i think it's
a really interesting
subject i actually broadcast on this
during this week with my good friend
manila chan
on in question on rt america which i do
every night monday to friday and
the way i put it there was that a camel
had got stuck in the eye
of a needle and that's what it looked
like to me
the the truth is these container ships
are getting bigger and bigger
but the suez canal is not getting bigger
and bigger
and in fact the more you dredge it the
more you
risk instability of the banks
and so on so we have all of our eggs
in the sewers canal basket
and that has never been healthy
and i talked to manila in the week about
the plan the united states had believe
this or not
in 1963 the u.s planned
using 25 nuclear bombs
nuclear explosions to carve a new canal
through israel to the sea
and they only actually abandoned that
plan not be for the danger of radiation
but but because of the cost of it
but there are other routes there are two
problems with those
other routes the route around the horn
of africa takes two weeks longer
and of course the
waters off the horn of africa are
absolutely infested with piracy and
that there's lots of pirates of course
big pirates and small pirates
these are small pirates and anyone
sailing past
is at very real risk of being bordered
uh by pirates and uh health or ransom
but there is a second route and you may
think i'm crazy
advancing it but the northern
uh ru that russia could
facilitate uh with its uh nuclear
icebreaking
technology uh is actually shorter than
the suez canal route
much shorter therefore than the horn of
africa route
and the ability to keep it clear for uh
tanker
and uh container ship traffic
is now with us these uh nuclear
icebreakers that russia has
can clear a path for anything
instantaneously
so i i think we need to look again
at this policy of having all our eggs in
the sewers canal
uh basket oh but thanks for that call
dale is in
surrey let's hear from him dale go ahead
hi george thanks for having me on the
show again welcome um first of all i
just want to let you know
before i get to my main point that apple
is actually the biggest company in the
world if you go by market
capitalization rather than revenue yeah
it's difficult to do that though
between different sectors uh but
uh i take your point i'm sure the editor
will be making that point to me
excellent um so i want to get your
opinion on two things the first one
being probably seen in the news that
china's um
boycotting along with the population
nike adidas
um burberry all these big companies that
are making false accusations uh
against china with rc uh shenzhen
china is fighting back on all fronts
yeah and because i think they have had
enough for this but western anti
trying to propagate out by these
companies as well they might
yeah yeah i also want to get your
opinion about the um
the mps that have been sanctioned uh
by china and alfred doing exactly the
same things
uh china well it is funny dale uh
the bleating that has occurred both in
the european parliament and now
in the british parliament about china
sanctioning them
when they are literally never done
sanctioning
china as uh the old fella said in
dad's army they don't like up them some
of them do
as it happens but they don't like
sanctions up them they are
more than happy to dish them out but
they are
not happy at all when there is a
reciprocation
china is being framed on all
manner of subjects but on no
subject more than the fake
allegations of uh repression
and even ridiculously enough genocide
against the uyghur muslim minority
in sink yang province this is
a bigger canard than any
since the uh weapons of mass destruction
lie
that dragged us into the catastrophe of
the iraq war
and occupation the proliferation of
al-qaeda
the spawning of isis and so on this is
such a
complete lie from exactly the same
people
who gave us the weapons of mass
destruction
lie it is such a complete lie
that china is not prepared any longer
to put up with it especially coming from
politicians and countries
that have actually been bombing invading
and occupying muslim countries for most
of the last
20 years you feel me
what was that um thing you mentioned
earlier about mps were actually telling
other mps not to focus too much on human
rights
exactly we sacked craig murray for over
focusing
on human rights in uzbekistan
but china has to be the whipping boy
uh on everything from tibet to
taiwan uh and china especially
is angry because it's quite plain
for lots of reasons including the one
i've just given
that these people doing this don't give
a toss
about muslims not a toss they're
prepared to bomb
sanction kill occupy muslims
everywhere they hate muslims everywhere
but they
sure love them in china china has
a problem with al-qaeda and isis
not with muslims the muslims in china
are thriving both in terms of their
population numbers
and their economic social cultural and
religious
well-being this is a gigantic
lie dale i'm glad that you gave me the
opportunity
to say so let's go to jamie in
malaga go ahead jamie hello george good
evening how are you
i'm good i'm fighting on all cylinders
now
excellent i can hear it fantastic um
thank thanks for taking my caller it was
really just to say how
totally appalled i am at the judgment
against craig murray
yeah it's hard heartbreaking literally
absolutely disgraceful i just think
you know there they are trying to
silence yet another journalist yeah
with their man who has been campaigning
for the other
silenced journalist juliana
exactly exactly did you know that uh
julian i think it was this morning
received a letter from the pope
oh i'm very glad to hear that i didn't
know that no tell us
what you know yeah there was there was a
statement uh
by stella morris on on twitter this
afternoon where she says
that uh the prison chaplain
delivered the letter to julian this
morning
so i'm very glad to hear that yeah it's
brilliant it's brilliant
so really that was what i wanted to say
yeah hallelujah
and uh god bless the pope that was a
very
important and noble thing for him to
have done a good friend of mine uh
ambassador alicia castro the former
ambassador of argentina to london
who is a very good friend of julian
assange
and a very good friend of the pope she
has been
trying to interest his holiness
in this case for a very long time and
get him to
uh take action so maybe that is what has
happened
if ambassador alicia is listening
or ever hears this i take my hat off to
you for all that you did
to push the holy see into seeing
what exactly has been going on
with julian assange jamie in malaga
thank you very much
indeed for that call we're coming to the
end of the alex almond
poll uh so here's the next poll
should vaccine passports be mandatory
a yes b no c
only for travel you can vote now
on my twitter feed at
george galloway coming up after nine we
have of course
our own moats medic dr ranjit brah so
get your calls in now
if you want to ask the doctor a question
either about the vaccine or the vaccine
passports or anything
uh of that kind uh so the uk number
is 02077 982
two five five that's oh two oh seven
seven
nine eight two two five five or if
you're in the us
zero zero one seven five seven seven
four four four four eight zero
time for tariff in new orleans
go ahead tariff
how you doing mr george this is tyree
simon connor from new orleans louisiana
thank y'all for taking my call and thank
you for having this great show
thank you um i was uh um i was glad
when i saw that posting by on stella
morris that julian science received
a courage you know cursed me from hope
from the pope
pope francis and that was a good thing
and i'm glad the other caller brought it
up
um that that that that is a that is a
good blessing
yeah i hope that's that push the british
government to free him sooner than later
you know what i'm saying because we need
all the help to free him
then we gotta start working on craig
craig mori and the other journalists and
whistleblowers around the world to free
them as well
i'm also a whistleblower i'm a va
veteran's affairs of whistleblower my
name is tyrone simon
and also the u.s need
a serious trend data infrastructure
program
they got some places here the united
states
still don't have good running water i
come to find out jackson mississippi
last week
125 000 people still without water
because they bite their pipes bust
through the winter freeze
wow that that that's not right and flint
pipes have yet i i don't know if y'all
guess know about flint
yes the lead in the water yeah
yes their pipes haven't been replaced
yet
they still need help and they need to
get be all put on medicaid
medicare to take care of the hospital
bills because you have people
they have children being born with uh
learning disabilities from that person
you have people
suffering nerve damage from lead
poisoning you have people suffering
memory loss and all those things
and they don't have the money already
poor because the um
the um automotive industries it had
packed up and left and went to
the ship to mexico and other places
which
and that decimated michigan so
when flint and detroit used to be middle
class they're not middle class anymore
they
like poor joe biden have to
invest in michigan and flint they have
to invest in
um new jersey they pipes something wrong
with their pipes
houston and also jackson mississippi
matter of fact
all 50 800 counties and cities because
our pipes in the united states is like
third world nations are worse
wow you know in free joining science and
thank you for taking my call
thank you for our most powerful call uh
a tour of the horizon
but the fact that the united states has
a water pipe system comparable
in many parts of the country north and
south
of the country to as tariff puts a third
world country
is as powerful a case for the united
states paying more attention
to its own business and less attention
to other people's
business isn't it that's my view in any
case
if the united states would spend a
fraction
rebuilding its own country that it has
spent destroying
other people's countries if it spent as
much energy
in its political and media class on the
problems at home
in the united states as it spends on
trying to
solve problems in other people's
countries that would be a fine
thing and i think the people of the
united states
would probably thank them for it but
what do they matter
let's get the news with jamie law
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news the british
government remains confident everyone in
the uk will get a second dose of the
covert vaccine
within 12 weeks of their first the
culture secretary has said
questioned about the concerns over
vaccine supply
oliver dowden said we always knew there
would be ups and downs
adding that the timetable was on track
he said it was essential
to provide second doses and it would not
require mixing vaccines
dowden added that the modern jab was due
to arrive in the uk in
april it's the third vaccine of seven
that the uk has put in an order for
and the country has lined up to receive
17 million doses
so far more than 30 million uk adults
have received their first coronavirus
vaccine from either the pfizer
or the oxford jabs and more than 3
million of them
have had a second but vaccine supply
issues
have continued to make the rollout bumpy
earlier this month the nhs
warned of a significant reduction in
jabs available in england in
april and there has been a delay to
oxford astrazeneca shipments from india
there are also tensions from the eu over
the supply of jabs
low drivers cabin crew prison escorts
and seasonal workers entering
england from outside the uk will need to
take a covert 19 test within 48 hours of
arrival
the government has said those remaining
in the uk for longer than
two days will be required to take a
further test every three days
the new regime is intended to stop the
virus spreading
and new variants entering the new rules
take effect from the 6th of april
mp neil hanvey has become the second one
to defect from the snp to join
alex salmond's new pro scottish
independence party
alba the mp for kirk kaldi and
cowden beats said that alba provided
quote a tonic
for our movement on saturday former
justice secretary kenny mccaskill
announced he would also stand as a
candidate for alba
alex salmond launched the party on
friday with the aim of building
quote a super majority for independence
at hollyrood
after the election in may
suez canal salvage teams are alternating
between dredging
and tugging as they continue to try to
dislodge the massive container ship
blocking the busy waterway dredges have
so far shifted 27
000 cubic meters of sand to a depth of
18 meters with work set to continue
around the clock
the 400 meter long ever given became
jammed
diagonally across a southern section of
the canal in high winds more than five
days ago
halting shipping traffic in one of the
world's busiest waterways as of
yesterday 321 boats were waiting to get
through the canal including dozens of
container ships bolt carriers and oil
tankers
airstrikes that sent villagers fleeing
into the jungle show the situation in
myanmar is much
worse a humanitarian worker has said as
military
leaders reportedly partied on the
deadliest day of violence since last
month's coup
more gunfire has been reported today as
people gathered for the funeral of one
of at least 114 people
said to have been killed by security
forces yesterday
including a five-year-old boy and a
thirteen-year-old girl
local media is reporting that around
three thousand people from myanmar's
south
eastern current state have left the
country and crossed the border into
thailand
to escape the violence
despite the bloodshed protesters
returned to the streets today to demand
a return
to democracy david eubank founder of the
humanitarian group free burma rangers
said airstrikes on a village in karen
killed at least
three people and wounded eight others he
said the first airstrike struck around 8
30 pm local time on saturday
and more hit between 1 am and 2 am today
two top un officials condemned myanmar's
military junta today
in a joint statement today alice wairimu
and daratu
un special adviser on the prevention of
genocide
and michelle bachelet un high
commissioner for human rights
urged the myanmar military to
immediately stop killing the very people
it has a duty to serve and protect
a suspected suicide bomb attack outside
a catholic church in the indonesian city
of makassar
has left 14 people wounded police say an
explosion erupted as two attackers tried
to enter the church on palm sunday the
first day of easter
a destroyed motorbike and body parts
were found at the scene and police said
the two attackers had died
militant islamists have attacked
churches in the past but no group has
yet
said it was behind the bombing
indonesia's president joko widodo
condemned the act
as a terror attack facebook has frozen
venezuelan president nicolas maduro's
page
after he claimed without evidence that a
herbal remedy could cure covert 19.
he said in january that a time herb
solution could cure the disease
he will be unable to post for 30 days
the company said the leader has
repeatedly violated its policies on
coronavirus disinformation
maduro is not the only world leader to
face a ban from social media companies
over kovid
u.s president donald trump and brazil's
jaya bolsonaro have also faced action
over covert posts and finally a
six-year-old
boy has found a fossil dating back
millions of years in his garden
after receiving a fossil hunting kit for
christmas
siddhak singh jamaat known as sid said
he was excited to find the fossil in his
garden in warsaw
after digging for worms his father vish
singh was able to identify the horn
coral
through a fossil group he is a member of
on facebook the group identified the
find as most likely a rugosa coral
estimated to be between 251 and 488
million years old
singh senior said quote the period that
they existed was from between
500 million and 251 million years ago
the paleozoic era england at the time
was part of pangaea a landmass of
continents
england was all underwater as well
and that's the latest here on sputnik
news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
well the second poll has gone off like a
rocket should vaccine passports be
mandatory a
yes 23 up to be
no 55 down one
c only for travel 22
up one 746 people have voted
in about seven minutes you've got the
best part of an hour
to get your vote in now
we spoke of course about the travel
implications of the coronavirus to lisa
nand earlier
let's talk to our own medic moat's medic
dr
ranjit brah who's helped us through all
of this
through the entire pandemic dr brown
thank you
very much again for uh joining us it
looks like
this vaccine passport issue is going to
be
uh the next the next big tinfoil hat
conspiracy theory that's my take you may
have a different one
no need for us both to agree on it but
if i have a restaurant it's up to me
if i allow people who will not say
whether or not they've been vaccinated
into my restaurant
or not ditto of iowa on an airline
i understand that no medicine should be
compulsory but neither should it be
compulsory
for workplaces businesses
to allow people who refuse to get a
vaccine
into their premises you can't have it
both ways
uh that would be my take on it in any
case if
most of the anti-vaxxed people are very
proud of being
anti-backs so why wouldn't they
want to tell people that they have not
had
the vaccination where do you stand on
that doctor
george good to be with you uh
so i i have slightly mixed feelings as
you say
my general feeling is uh first do no
harm we're here to protect the public
there's a there's a really um cherished
bond of trust between
physicians between doctor and patient um
which
shouldn't be broken and that has to come
you know take into account the
you know views and and decision making
really really
our job is to empower our patients and
put them in control of their health now
of course infectious disease there is an
extra dimension as you say that you know
if i get infectious disease and i
freely go around trying to spread it to
everyone if i had hiv and i tried to
have unprotected sex with everyone i met
people would generally agree that was
morally
reprehensible uh there was no vaccine
for hiv so it's not
direct analysis but you know there's a
duty to protect others as well so i
think you know
coronavirus is an interesting uh um
the nature of the disease i think
informs
our opinion uh it's a disease which for
young fit patients you know is
is not particularly harmful this is
what's so strange about the disease and
why
there's so much kind of controversy
still persists around it but of course
for the elderly
for the vulnerable for the infirm it's
an extremely
harmful disease and
hence why that patient population in
particular have been you know
shielding they've been the most affected
in terms of the deaths around the
country
and they have been the first to be
vaccinated once you have vaccinated that
group of
patients actually the risk of death and
the risk of the disease falls
dramatically it's been the
the the role of the kova the
anti-vaxxers
the the covered deniers for want of a
better word the people who say this
whole thing is a conspiracy against the
public has been saying well copper is no
worse than the common cold that is
totally false there's no worse than the
flu that is totally false okay
it has been a much more severe disease
however
for a section of population young and
fit it's not
particularly you know worse for you than
the flu so if there are a group amongst
that population who feel they don't want
to
have the vaccine who would rather get
the
the virus essentially um well i think
you know
it's not the choice i would make it's
not the choice i would encourage i tend
to think we need to put
you know um preserve persuasion amongst
that group so
i wouldn't enforce um a covered uh uh
passport
but you know i'm not in control of
policy it's quite clear
the signals from government from
industry from other countries it will be
introduced it will affect travel
um and i don't think there's anything we
can do about it would i rail against it
would i make it a point of campaigning
probably not particularly i mean if i go
abroad and i want to visit a country
that has yellow fever and they make me
get a document to say how to get a fever
vaccine i think that's reasonable that's
probably their right so you know i can
see
both sides of the argument fundamentally
the vaccine is extremely efficacious and
extremely
safe um and it's the single thing that
we've probably done you know relatively
well
in the pandemic so i'm in favor of
people having the vaccine when it's
offered george
now how is the vaccination going uh
in in scotland uh where i live
uh it has slowed up i'm still waiting
for my second
jab and it's slowed up for reasons which
are not immediately
discernible uh some say that we're
running out of stock some say it's the
european union playing silly people with
the export of uh of vaccines and this is
tied up with
the astrazeneca issue that we have
discussed before
where millions of doses of this vaccine
are in the european union but not being
used
give us your overview on the state of
vaccination
in britain and in europe well it was
very interesting to see i don't know if
you're aware of boris johnson's comments
that he made to the 1922
uh committee just on tuesday um
apparently in a private zoo meeting but
that leaked out when he said uh
you know my friends the success of the
vaccination program was due to greed
and due to capitalism and he was
censored for being so open
and honest so there's unquestionably
there is a there is
money to be made i mean greed and
capitalism is not is not
you know synonymous with human
technology and its success there's no
question that
vaccinations had a key effect in britain
however it's also led to all the
many manifold failings of our handling
of the pandemic
probably 150 000 deaths failures over pp
ppe procurement failures over ventilated
procurement
um ignoring operation cygnus running
down the capacity of the nhs
uh you know the failure to protect the
nhs by safeguarding the pain conditions
of the nurses and doctors who know we
are offered a one percent pay rise
um the rank and manifest corruption if
you wanted any more evidence that our
politicians seek office not to serve the
public but to serve themselves to serve
their own wallets
you don't have to look a lot further
than the revelations
about um uh citigroup um
and cameron uh and the uh uh the affair
that he was mixed up mixed up with green
hill
uh capital so you know there's again and
again and again
from you know matt hancock giving 250
million to his is publican to the amount
of money that was wasted on ineffectual
track and trace system we have seen that
the profit motive putting profit at the
heart of the response to the pandemic
has
been what has gone wrong however you
know
vaccines are made by these massive
multinational companies
and vaccine itself is a technology which
has done
very well i think you know if you know
our government were truly worried about
the
health and well-being of the population
they would accept vaccine from any and
every source is clear that they have
only accepted it from these very big
wealthy
in boris johnson's word greedy
capitalist producers
they haven't accepted the sputnik
vaccine which is probably the most
efficacious and relatively cheap they
are very shortly to roll out the um
moderna vaccine which actually had uh
several billions worth of
funding um from the u.s government which
wasn't developed by the
risk appetite of prinets uh private
finance initiative at all but in fact
we've had massive
state funding they will roll that out
but they will not
roll out uh vaccines of people they seem
to be their strategic
competitors so you know this cuts across
the claim
that their motivation is the health and
well-being of the british public
that said it cuts across the claim in
fact it doesn't bear a moment's
examination if it was capitalism
and greed then the doctor would uh
would negotiate with us before he put
the needle
uh in our arms if it was down to
the market they would have auctioned off
the vaccinations uh instead of saying
the 80 year olds first
they'd say who's prepared to pay would
be like an auction with a hammer
yes it goes to you you've bid x
thousand for your vaccine also the
oxford
astrazeneca uh is uh selling at cost
price it's quite a high cost price
compared to
sputnik and to the chinese version but
if
if oxford astrozenica were obeying
the dictat of capitalism and greed
uh their their injections would cost
vastly more
especially in the beginning than they
actually did
cost the doctors would negotiate with us
before actually doing the work to give
it
to us the firemen would negotiate with
the homeowner
on the pavement outside how much is it
worth to you for me to plunge
into your burning building and rescue
your
uh imperiled child it's it's actual
nonsense doctor yeah i think that's
extremely
true georgia and if you want to see the
extremes to which sometimes private
healthcare
can go to there are examples you know of
private health care firms in the united
states in india in other places
performing unnecessary procedures actual
bodily harm
in order to take the maximum from their
patients pocket
or from their patients insurance plan
i'm afraid to say what we're seeing is
our healthcare going further and further
down that road it's interesting to see
um the signet group which is um a large
uh subsidiary british subsidiary of a
large american multinational uh
health firm have appointed dame claire
garada then claire garada is a
psychiatrist and gp
uh who was formerly president of the
royal college of physicians she's
was actually elected uh to that to that
position
on the basis of her being
anti-privatization but now she's been
elected to the board
of this very large private health
conglomerate um
has been uh chosen by says picked out by
sir simon stevens
um has obviously been made a dame
uh for this uh championing of this uh
interaction between
private um finance and the nhs so we're
seeing the constant
encroachment in every sphere but also
the nhs of
private capital upon our model of
healthcare delivery and this goes hand
in hand of course with what we
previously discussed which was the
56 gp practices which passed into the
hands of
essentially um us private yeah a
corporation just a couple of weeks back
george let's take a call uh doctor from
ian and hans law ian go ahead what would
you like to ask the doctor
uh good evening um i'd like to ask you
dr bra
what is the limiting factor of
two options on the vaccine roller is it
because we don't have enough vaccines or
is it because our distribution
points have choke points we can't get
them out fast enough
what's what do you think's going on or
is it not an issue
thanks for your question i think
initially the the probably the rate
limiting step is the overall supply of
vaccine um having said which if we've
vaccinated 30 million it's very close to
half of the population they are the most
at risk uh we know three and a half
people have now had their second doses
so you know it would be possible
if the nhs staffing levels were higher
to
administer more if we had more vaccine
it is possible to manufacture more
vaccine i think
that that has essentially been a supply
issue
but that said if we can if you compare
ourselves to other countries
the supply has been you know relatively
um
relatively well rolled out
uh thanks ian uh ronwell in chicago
is the birthday boy and he has a
question for the doctor
happy birthday ron well
thank you george galloway you're welcome
many happy returns to you what would you
like to ask dr ranjit
um all right so um dr rhonda bar um
i really need you to send me a happy
birthday so anyway
um what were
that like um how uh like
like when um would the spokes find or
come to us
because most of my friends are
vaccinated
within my family um
i believe of pfizer i believe and i'd
rather be vaccinated with spookney's
vibes
are you and me both ronwell i asked if i
could take the vaccine
the sputnik 5 vaccine live on air here
in the mother of all talk shows but uh
the british authorities wouldn't allow
the vaccine
to come into britain is a big scandal
that isn't a doctor
i think it is georgia it it says ronwell
happy birthday uh con congratulations
um uh is it's a totally reasonable
request to say i would like to be
vaccinated with a particular vaccine
however
i don't think the us will grant
sputnik 5 a vaccine that's not because
it's not an excellent
license in the united states that's not
because it's not an excellent vaccine
it's because that they are into trade
protectionism in the same way that our
own countries while strongly accusing
china or vaccine nationalism
a very aggressive propaganda in the
beginning stages
middle stage of the pandemic of of
saying that
china should play reparations you know
of hundreds of billions to the world of
accusing china being
uh the the uh party who was at fault for
the entire pandemic
uh all of this kind of propaganda is
grist to their mill um
and we can see with the recent
developments this week just how
how far that antipathy to china in the
us and britain is going
china finally defending itself and
hitting back with the very obvious you
know
there's like an open goal waiting uh
to be to be scored george laid out the
case very well early on i won't
recapitulate it but it's good to see
china and and
russia um defending themselves but the
the chances
of you know us and britain eu countries
accepting chinese and russian vaccines
are not related to their efficacy
and they're very low precise because
they see them as the key global economic
competitors and it's that it's the
economic factors
throughout the pandemic which have
conditioned the response of our
governments and why i think
um much as i'd like to see sputnik 5 in
particular
given a license in britain i am not
holding my breath i do not think
it will happen enjoy the rest of your
birthday
ron well of course this conflict dr
ranji it's not just between
east and west uh the the european union
countries are fighting like
a ferrets in a sack with each other and
with us
it's hard to believe that brexit isn't
part of the reason for that isn't it
it is there's definitely part of it but
you know the the eu with a very large
450 million population
um have are experiencing no doubt about
it
another wave third wave fourth wave
third wave of the
of the of the of the pandemic and you
know um
if you see the numbers of cases france
has leapfrogged britain
and russia um you know which has become
the fourth
largest number of test proven cases in
the world um
it's gone to four and a half million
cases close to 100
000 deaths italy's got a hundred
thousand deaths from covet so
europe due to its poor vaccination
status as well as its poor
pharmaceutical
non-pharmaceutical measures is suffering
greatly and they have a real
unquestionably supply problem um
due to slightly uh com com reasons of
competition
um they see that astrazeneca as a as a
british
uh competitor to the pfizer they have
rubbished it at the early stages uh the
french president macron was
actively involved in that they've had to
step down from that but nevertheless as
you say
many doses that are not being given
they're threatened nevertheless to limit
the export of
doses of pfizer from the eu to britain
on the basis that they need it more
they've limited the export of doses to
other countries as well
uh chancellor angela merkel of germany
has
openly said on a number of occasions now
in conflict with the central operators
of the eu
that she thinks germany should give a
license to and roll out the sputnik
vaccine they're in desperate
need of giving it to their population
and it's quite clearly
a sensible thing for them to do but
again the interests of their large
um big pharmaceutical companies of their
of their banking sector of their finance
sector
mean that they don't want to lose that
intense world competition they don't
understand the signal
um that they are incapable of managing
that through their own technology and
development
so there's a massive conflict between
the health and well-being of the working
people
of the european union countries and
large capital which only wants to
promote their own
technology in order to make a lot of
money out of the vehicle of the pandemic
from selling their own vaccine to the
rest of the world george
gerard didn't kill winning in airshow
gerard go ahead
good evening george good evening dr
braar and thanks for taking my call i
would just say that i'm a young guy i
thought he was that i'm definitely going
to get the vaccine so
i would hope that all my peers do that
as well um
my concern george and dr barr is this um
ever since the beginning of the pandemic
well no actually ever since the killing
of george floyd actually we have seen
a lot of different protests in this
country some goods
some noble causes like black lives
matter some um idiotic like anti-vaccine
protests
the problem is i know there's this issue
about you know does it affect ethnic
minorities more than white people the
virus but
inherently it's not a racist disease it
affects
everyone men women uh the elderly the
young
but every time i see a protest like the
bristol one
people packed in like sardines my head
is in my hands because i'm just thinking
myself
these are people they're going to be
young people there who have not had the
vaccine yet
potentially getting it potentially
spreading it to their parents the
grandparents i'm just thinking myself
but doing this consistently the last
year protests demonstrations when we're
told by the medical professionals
do not gather in large groups it just
seems such a contradiction and it's the
worst thing to be doing
especially when the end is safe when
there is light at the end of the tunnel
why i wish people would stay i know
there's noble causes out there but i'm
just so concerned
like i say in my head in my hands i
don't know if you as well doctor
at these protests again no matter how
noble the cause is
because this is going to surely spread
the virus powerful call gerard
thanks very much for making it doctor
i i i i understand the points that jar
makes but i have a slightly different
uh different take i think so i think you
know um
yes at the beginning so if you look at
when there are very few cases in the
country
it would have been fantastic to prevent
them
spreading you're stopping foreign
football teams from coming and playing
games or from hot spots to our country
stopping flights from hotspots to our
country
um all of those kind of measures would
have been sensible stopping
massive race course meetings that would
have been sensible stopping people
of course have mainly spread it through
work and school throughout the pandemic
really you know 12 or 13
um actually sorry no more like 20
million of us have been regularly
going to work many have been regularly
going to school so you know and it's
been the poorest of course who have been
the most affected because they've been
least able to shelter at least able to
stop their economic activity because
then they've
faced a very real threat of starvation
so it's not been
equally distributed it's been the
poorest most of all and of course as the
economic crisis has hit
the poor and the vulnerable have been
particularly hard hit so they are
rightly you know up in arms about the
many different social conditions that
they face and i do feel that a lot of
the pro i mean
if you look at the sarah everard protest
for example a socially distant
outside protest most participants young
women most
most wearing masks uh coming to express
very legitimate outpouring of grief
um and um really kind of
i guess the protest against the
perpetrators of that crime as well
um the very heavy-handed policing was
justified on the basis of stopping the
spread of chronovirus
to me that does not scan at all and
particularly now not just with the end
in sight but actually if
30 million people have been vaccinated
then it essentially means that the most
vulnerable to the coronavirus are now
protected
if we look at the rates we didn't
actually mention them but you know we're
talking about this week
uh 450 deaths so not not zero but but
far fewer and that's kind of the tail
end of many people of course
have had prolonged uh illnesses from
from this
wave but the people who are down
actually in hospitals down to five
five percent of the hospital population
and really only about 38 000 test proven
cases
a week we talked about now quite a small
number on protest itself will have
a minimal impact upon the
further spread of corona virus and i do
think it's actually unlikely we're going
to see the kind of
wave that they're currently experiencing
in europe so now more than ever
it's important i think with a large
percentage of the population possibly
the unemployment rate
the the economically inactive rate of
the population
going up higher than we've seen in our
lifetime
from around the quarter 25 percent to
around the 33 to one-third
percent of our working age population
are not in work some of them very
very wealthy the vast majority will not
be so there will be many legitimate
grievances
and we've seen the crime courts uh
police sentencing bill forgive me i've
got the name slightly wrong
which is extremely draconian act not to
say that there aren't already many
powers resting with the states to curb
demonstration but we're going to have a
very discontented population
who have increasingly fewer and fewer
avenues to voice
their um opposition to the fact that
their position is becoming more
marginalized but they're becoming poorer
they're facing real problems and at the
moment it's incredible really in in the
face of the mismanagement of this
pandemic to see that the tories riding
high in the polls
but that's a reflection of people's
disillusionment with
labor and so a real political opposition
needs to come forward
an element of that will be
demonstrations i think covid less and
less
will be seen as a legitimate reason to
curb
protest and demonstration i'm sorry if
that's at odds
um with with your view or all of that
but increasingly
really increasingly that's my opinion
you're here to give uh
your opinion to the listeners and
viewers thanks gerard
mark is in leicestershire go ahead mark
hi mark hi george hi ranji um thanks for
taking my call
it is um it's just a call regarding herd
immunity
and i know it's obviously started
initially when the um corona vibe has
actually come about but
my point now i've not really i can't
really find any information and there's
nobody's really talking about in the
actual media but
um herd immunities defines that
obviously when you actually catch a
virus you cannot pass it on
um but with having the first vaccine and
the second vaccine
you can actually catch coronavirus still
and you can still pass it on
and i just wonder what your thoughts
were regarding the hood immunity
okay in that regard thanks mark doctor
thanks mark so i heard means he had two
aspects to it didn't it so i had the
original
um uh boris johnson and dominic cummings
strategy was essentially do nothing let
the virus run throughout the population
and just let it run its course
we know if we could really let it run
its course without any vaccination
intervening and supervening
then probably that would have led to
over a million deaths in the country
estimates between half a million and a
million
but looking at the rates as they were
unfolding without vaccination
probably closer or even in excess of a
million deaths a very large number of
deaths that we would have talked about
by a natural herd immunity
um and that just simply to me expressed
the fact that again in in the word of
of dominant comings himself it was hurt
immunity protect the economy and if a
few uh
pensioners die so be it the fact that
you know the lives of working people is
worth little to them
and the main thing was the economy they
couldn't protect the economy of course
because of the world economic
uh collapse and depression that we're
facing in terms of the vaccine of course
vaccine is a different thing so if we do
achieve a certain rate of vaccination in
the population
then we will essentially stop the spread
of the vaccine there can be some
variance there will be fewer variants to
the extent that we
have a successful vaccine a rollout so
you know we will achieve i mean if you
look at herd immunity as a general
strategy within the absence of
vaccination
sweden was always held up as a glowing
example it's now
widely recognized that that's not the
case it had rates of 12 or 15
times in terms of deaths and cases
compared to its uh
scandinavian neighbors who had similar
population
ages and conditions of existence so just
heard immunity by itself without
really good non-pharmaceutical measures
to protect the
working lives of people was poor herd
immunity meaning vaccinate enough of the
population you really do protect the
population
yes that will work thanks mark
john is in thirsk go ahead john hi
george hi
doctor hi um my question
is um my partner and i have both had our
first vaccines
my partner has ms and we've been
incredibly
kind of um judicious in terms of going
out and what have you she's been out
four times
since march last year
you know so it it that's tough for her
um this question of the vaccine passport
neither of us have smartphones and
that's
not a question of kind of economics it's
a question that we don't want them
um and it seems to me that the entire
scheme is predicated upon
actually having these forms rather than
having something
that is either paper or or or
you know what was originally suggested
with um
uh national park you know not national
passport so you know um
yeah yeah but yeah as was pointed out
earlier
john i've been to many countries
in in what is called the third world
where i had to produce a certificate
that i had
been vaccinated against
particular diseases in their country
there's nothing novel about that now you
can show it on a bit of paper or you can
show
on your phone uh i'm struggling with why
why this is such a big issue for you and
others
but the government seems to be going
down the road of only having and
allowing it
on on smartphones well
you might need to get a smartphone then
john but
otherwise you could not travel to places
that were requiring you
to show that you'd had a vaccine well i
don't what do i just want to go to my
local pub in my local restaurant well
there'll be a market in that there'll be
some pubs that will not want to look at
your vaccination record
and there'll be other pubs that will uh
that's uh almost inevitable i would have
thought
but if i own a pub uh i never could or
would of course
being a total non-drinker but if i owned
a pub
i might well take the view that for the
protection of my staff
myself and the rest of my customers
i only want people that have been
vaccinated to come and drink in it
what would be wrong what would be wrong
i understand that but why should
it be
a technology-based thing what's your
alternative
well we have some kind of documents it
is presumably when you went abroad
you didn't have a smartphone no i didn't
these these were in the days long before
uh
smartphones i'll ask the doctor what he
thinks hold on john
doctor thanks george hi john yeah i mean
there are still many people who don't
even have access to email little and
smartphones so you know in as much as
they uh
our government might might make
documentation compulsory
uh there would be a duty on them to make
it compulsory in many forms such that it
can be accessed
um i'm not really gonna comment any
further on
on the concept of vaccine passports per
se
um there are there are pros and cons of
them it's quite clear that there is
significant mistrust of what should be
a very straightforward technology a
medicine i mean if you don't get your
children vaccinated
and there are some parents who really
don't want to um
it has been made appear some time ago
a question of whether you are
causing deliberate harm to your children
you know it's arguable that you
are you're imposing your beliefs on them
and affecting their health
so these are questions which are not new
and i'm certainly not an
anti-vaxxer i'm very much in favor of
vaccines i've had
loads and my children have had their
normal uh vaccinations
and vaccinations as a technology which
is
one of the few you know almost unalloyed
stories of success of the medical
profession but you know because
there is this mistrust raised by the
whole handling of the pandemic the
massive levels of corruption we've seen
from our government the distrust in in
our in our ruling class
the antithesis between this incredibly
wealthy bubble in
in westminster and vast sways of the
country which are de-industrialized
going through poverty the most
marginalized sections of the community
who are faring worse from coronavirus
have least
trust in the government and in this
business and therefore do not
trust you know i think it's a sad irony
that they will be
least likely to have the vaccine but i
personally uh i'm not in favor of
absolutely
coercing them and and forcing them to do
so by saying
you you will be further you will
experience further social uh
ostrification i mean i do think it's a
problem that
really wouldn't exist were there not
this antipathy between the government
and the populist
and i do think this is a misguided
instance of being
against the rollout of a perfectly good
technology because of the system which
is offering it
to us so i understand where people are
coming from but overall you know the
vaccines are very safe
they offer a way forward they offer it's
like a get out of jail
card free i mean boris johnson the tory
government are riding on a wave of
like enthusiasm for the fact we're going
to be moving through this because of
vaccination when really
you know they should be they should be
in the dock of a court for all of the
all of the mismanagement and corruption
that they have um you know really
perpetrated against the british people
throughout this pandemic george
john thank you very much uh by the way
doctor
uh there's been a massive swing on the
pole these things happen of course
uh should vaccine passports be mandatory
a
yes 46 up
24 no 34
down 22 or only for
travel 20 down to 2 2290
people have voted thank you as always
doctor
for helping us through yet another week
in the great coronavirus
saga let me take a 60 second break why
don't you
radio sputnik
[Music]
call me come and have a go if you think
you're hard enough
don't bring up a false name come on air
call me and let's have this mata out
that's 2016's argument michael i'm no
longer arguing with you
about the merits of brexit i'm arguing
with you
about democracy about the right
of the majority to have their decision
their vote implemented this match
[Music]
i want a referendum let me put that in
capital letters
if you think this year which is shaping
up already
to be an honest miserableness
for the snp if you think this is your
year
go ahead come on let's have it out
but no george it's not as simple as that
right have you seen the documentary
about cambridge analytica and people who
work there
have you looked at this and you know
nothing about that i'm not interested in
precisely but i'm not sure
about them i'm not interested in them
bruce because
it's all a red herring just like
russiagate
was a red herring do you only want to
hear voices
that agree with you because if you do
you're not clever enough to be at this
open
university of the airwaves in fact you
need to go back
to remedial and learn something about
what democracy
and freedom of speech actually mean
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have as long as you have
questions
we'll keep asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
should vaccine passports be made
mandatory the poll
is going absolutely mad so if you want
to affect
the result you better get on either my
telegram t dot me
forward slash george galloway or uh here
on my twitter feed at george galloway
guy is in stoke with a very
sensitive topic go ahead guy
yeah good evening george good evening to
you nice to hear from you again
yeah yeah it's uh it's miss akuri
yes who is she's a model
she's a pole dancer and she's an i.t
consultant
but she definitely needs therapy because
apparently
she fell in love with boris johnson
i don't know about a mantle uh quite a
few
quite a few of them have you know you
must have something guy
well i'll tell you what she got george
she got 125 000 pounds worth of
taxpayers money maybe that's what it was
which is what the yeah maybe she's a lot
smarter than i thought
um the point of the call is why the how
isn't the bbc and the other major news
channels in this country
uh reporting this this this story of
before i've been on the phone i've
googled it i've looked on the online
channels of those news companies and
there's not one word about it
now i ain't interested in johnson
or curie i'm interested in taxpayers
money
and and surely i'm not the only person
in this country who thinks
that he used taxpayers money
to get sexual favors from that woman
well uh i mean part of the problem will
be
uh how to prove that and if
one were to be sued by boris johnson on
that one would
have to prove it uh and that is uh
perhaps a formidable reason why only the
mirror
went with the story today as i
understand it boris johnson
is denying uh these allegations and it's
worth making the point guy
so did jennifer akuri uh until today
deny it she denied that she had a
sexual relationship with boris johnson
but she has changed her tune
today uh boris bonk's
blonde would be the least shocking story
or least surprising one at least of the
of the year or any year we know that he
is uh a wretched low-life
cheater and liar deceiver and adulterer
and
fornicator and father of
uh of uh children even
of married women leaving the married
woman and her
husband to bring up the child the poor
husband
imagining that the child was his there's
nothing
that boris johnson has not done
he's a low life high born
highfaluting low life that we know
and that isn't going to bring them down
but if it were to be established
that the six-figure sum of taxpayers
money that was given
to jennifer akuri was not given for the
purposes
that were officially on the
papers if the use of that money was not
as it was
intended to be if her presence on all
these
trade missions and so on had more to do
with her availability to him in the
evening time
than any genuine trade
purpose then boris johnson would be in
very very serious
trouble in other words it won't be the
sex that gets some
guy it will be if anything does
the corruption angle of that story if
true guy thanks for the call malcolm in
glasgow
go ahead malcolm quick follow-up uh
george i i spoke to you earlier about a
story about the
the western islands oh yes yes yes it
actually appeared on craig murray's blog
which is subsequently taken down
and i actually say there was a case in
auburn and the guy was
cleared of all charges so i'm sure i can
say there was professor woolhouse that
went there with his wife
it was isle of lismore and the police
arrived on the island to persecute this
old man against somebody who was a
scottish adviser
advising and doing the wrong thing
against his own advice
i'm scared to even talk about this in
scotland george
yeah well we have reached that situation
that's true
george but before i go before you take
over which i'm i'm i'm delighted to hear
what you're going to say
is when it gets to a stage where george
say we're 50 50.
we had a call in 2014. say we're 51.49
to get you into the stage where you're
getting threatened to your life get me
to get criticized from posting a
positive uk thing on my facebook do
these guys not have a life
get on with things get over the pandemic
and move on
i mean we do 70 of our trade with
england for god's sake
get a life well malcolm that's very much
my
point of view uh but roughly the country
is divided down the middle now i want to
say uh this is a controversial point
that you cannot split up a country on 50
50 51 49 you can't do that
because actually the principal
consequence of the breaking up of
britain or secondary consequence rather
would be the breaking up of scotland
because if you look at the
political map of scotland support for
separatism is confined to a
an exceedingly tiny geographically
speaking
exceedingly tiny part of the country
the vast expanses of the north of the
islands
of the south where i live uh are
completely against
uh separatism uh and so
uh it's not a realistic uh proposition
but the british government
better get busy in establishing
clarity on what circumstances
and by what mechanism any part of the
united kingdom could secede
from the union it simply won't be
acceptable for on a
75 percent turnout secession to win
by 50.1 uh to 49.9 that's ridiculous
and could only be a recipe for
trouble maybe even serious real
trouble malcolm god bless you john is in
dorset go ahead john hello
george hello good evening um i just i
just want to be slightly controversial
and um point out that i think it's wrong
to give preferential treatment to
religion
all religions any religion no matter
what they do what
i i it puzzles me how they get
um uh they seem to be always in
near the seat of power they're not in
the in in the sea of power
then they're they're close by we've got
them in the house of laws they've got
archbishops they've got absolutely
nothing to do with politics
it's an influence in law anyway to get
to my point uh
this week uh a school teacher showed a
cartoon
now don't cut me off yet i'm not gonna
say i'm gonna cut you off no no i'm not
gonna cut you off it's a very important
thing well well i i appreciate that now
the fact is that um
he was allegedly threatened with death
uh the the school that he was teaching
at is 85 percent
muslim i understand i don't know i'm
only just going on what i've read in the
newspapers
and they're allowed to uh threaten
somebody with ending his life
now i try to get on another uh can you
tell me something
just tell me something before you go on
uh yes
where was that death threat from human
by which means it was supposed to have
been from
from uh parents that were standing at
the school gates
or representing those parents that
standing at the school gate
i'm sympathetic to the general point i
suspect that you are
going to make uh but we have to but we
but we do have to be exact
i myself have not seen a death threat
but of course in france
there hold on in france
there wasn't just a death threat the
teacher was beheaded
so this is a matter of the gravest
significance and importance go on john
absolutely
now that was what i was just about to
allude to was the fact that
i tried to get onto an inferior radio
station
and the boat cut me off because he
didn't allow me to finish
because he said because i must admit i
did use colourful language when i
compared religion to the crate twins
and i i i must agree maybe that is a bit
strong but i don't think it's as strong
as sending out a death threat to people
and if if death threats if death threats
were
sent out it seems it seems that neither
of us have actually seen a death threat
no well let me tell you something george
if i may yeah
um you usually get in the message with
any religion i've ever
read about or heard about is that be
good and kind
or else now that is a bit that worries
me about all religion
is that there's last two words or else
it's
i'm cutting you short not at all because
of the subject matter
but because of the hour john we're only
seven minutes six minutes away from the
end of the show
and i need to respond to this
issue uh first of all i am a religious
believer my children go to a roman
catholic
school because i want them to be
brought up in that religious ethos
that's my right
they are my children not yours or
anyone else's and i have every right to
send them
to a religious school and i'm very glad
that i
do so i believe in
an atmosphere of godliness because i
believe in god and i believe
in the message of jesus that
we should uh love one another we should
love our neighbors we should
do good or else
yes there you go i've admitted it i do
believe that there is a judgment day
and on that judgment day those that have
done evil will be
somehow punished i don't know the
details i haven't got there
yet but i do believe that i'm entitled
to have my children so educated um
the muslim parents uh in batley
uh a town i know well are equally
entitled to
send their children to religious schools
the problem is
this particular school is not a
religious school
now for muslims depictions
of the prophet muhammad are forbidden
but this is not a muslim country and so
you cannot forbid it
you can say that it's very unwise to do
it
and i do say it was very unwise of this
teacher to
do it he or she must have known
what the response would be
but now that it has happened uh the life
of the teacher must be preserved
and protected and we cannot possibly
allow
any person or group of persons to
threaten
death speak as someone who was
threatened with death
just last weekend or worse
to actually attempt to bring about the
death
of someone who has offended others
so this is not a muslim country
if you absolutely want a guarantee
that no one will ever by any means or
rather
depict the prophet muhammad then you
better go and live in a muslim country
you cannot insist upon that in britain
at the same time we have
the right to publish uh pictures
uh of uh the muslim prophet we have that
right
but because we have that right doesn't
mean we need to exercise it
one has to weigh the consequences in
terms of social peace and so on
uh if one exercises one's right
but it was exercised by that teacher
and the absolute priority now is to
protect
the life of the teacher john i'm sure
we'll come back to this
subject and give it longer and you'll be
welcome uh to
contribute i promise you last call i
suspect
from douglas in glasgow go ahead douglas
hi george regarding one of your calls
earlier about your human rights in china
oh yeah yeah
i've been i've got no accident with
china i think what i've done for
the people economically is amazing but
just regarding some of the historical
things that have happened in china
and knowing that they are relatively
authoritarian regime
yeah how can you just totally discount
there being any truth
and the accusations of what's going on
for two reasons douglas first of all i
know the truth uh and secondly i
look at the people that are making the
allegations
and i have no compunction at all in
dismissing them
first because i know the truth and
second because i know the people making
the accusations
are liars that's that's why i do it
douglas
i'm only asking how you know the truth
then uh how i know the truth is i've
studied the matar
intensively intensively the source of
these
bogus fake allegations about uyghurs
uh are the very sources that
can be relied upon to bring you the fake
news
on any subject you like what is it
crimea
what is it the ukraine what is it iraq
what is it libya what is it syria
and any anytime you need it these same
people will come up with these stories
so
it is absolutely untrue it's the
opposite
of the truth the uyghurs in china
are flourishing their population is
flourishing
their economy is flourishing their
cultural life is flourishing
their religious life is flourishing
there are more
mosques in sinc yang province
more mosques in one province in china
cinqiang where the uyghurs live than
there are
in the entirety of the united states
of america in fact only saudi arabia
has more mosques per muslim
than the senkyang province in china
does it is a bright shining
light douglas i know that and i know the
people who are telling you
otherwise a liar so you know
fool me once a shame on you
fill me twice shame on me
douglas don't get fooled again
they fooled you over iraq they fooled
you over syria
they fooled you over libya they fooled
you over war after war after war
for goodness sake don't fall for it all
over again that's a sign of madness
it's been marvelous for me hope it was
for you
[Music]
so
you